GOOD AFTERNOON EVERYONE I'M
GOING TO MAKE SEVERAL
ANNOUNCEMENTS TODAY TO EXPLAIN
THE PROCESSES WE'VE DEVELOPED
TO CONTINUE OUR ESSENTIAL WORK.
DURING THE PANDEMIC FOR THOSE
OF YOU FAMILIAR WITH THIS
PROCESS WE REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR PATIENCE WHILE I GO
THROUGH IT YET AGAIN FOR THOSE
WHO MIGHT BE TUNING IN FOR THE
VERY FIRST TIME. LET ME COVER
THE TECHNICAL SIDE OF THINGS
FOR TODAY. IN RESPONSE TO THE
COBIT NINETEEN EMERGENCY AND TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC SENATORS AND
SENATE STAFF WE MUST LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS AND IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH STATE AND LOCAL
ORDERS THE SENATE WILL BE
HOLDING THIS ESSENTIAL HEARING.
AND WE'VE MADE NECESSARY
ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL PRACTICES
IN ORDER TO ENSURE THAT THE
PUBLIC HAS ACCESS TO OUR
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. WHILE
CONDUCTING THE HEARING IN A WAY
THAT PROTECTS THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF PUBLIC AND OF OUR
EMPLOYEES. TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC TO TWO HEARING
ROOMS TO THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW.
AND WILL BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY. FOR INDIVIDUALS
WISHING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT TOLL
FREE NUMBER. AND ACCESS CODE IS
POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. IT WILL BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN AND TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. EIGHT
SEVEN SEVEN TWO TWO SIX EIGHT
ONE EIGHT NINE. THE ACCESS CODE
IS. TWO EIGHT SEVEN SIX ZERO
FIVE NINE WILL DISPLAY A COUPLE
TIMES AS WE GO BUT THERE IT IS
FOR THE START OF THE MEETING.
WHEN WE MOVED TO PUBLIC COMMENT
A MODERATOR WILL IDENTIFY YOU
INDIVIDUALLY OPEN YOUR LAN AND
AT THAT TIME YOU MAY ADDRESS
THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE NOTE THAT
IN ORDER FOR US TO HEAR YOU
CLEARLY AND TO AVOID ANY
FEEDBACK YOU MUST BE YOU THE
DEVICE YOU WERE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON. PARTY GIVING YOUR
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND SO WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY. AND ANY
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE DISRUPTIVE
MAY BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE
MEETING SERVICE ARE HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. WHILE EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE THE HEARING PROCESS
AND CONDUCTOR HEARINGS. IT IS
CLOSE TO THE SAME MANNER AS IS
CUSTOMARY THERE MAY BE SOME LAG
TIMES. FOR PARTICIPANTS
ADJUSTING TO OUR NEW ONLINE
TOOL SO AGAIN PLEASE BE PATIENT
SO EVERYONE WILL BE ABLE TO BE
HEARD. ALSO ON BEHALF OF OUR
COURT REPORTER. I WILL ASK ALL
SPEAKERS MY COLLEAGUES ALSO AND
WITNESSES A LIGHT TO SPEAK
SLOWLY AND CLEARLY. AND SO
BEFORE WE BEGIN TODAY'S AGENDA
WE MUST ESTABLISH A QUORUM. AS
A REMINDER COLLEAGUES WILL HAVE
TO TURN ON YOUR MICROPHONES FOR
ROLL CALL AND EVERY TIME WE
VOTE. SO MADAM SECRETARY
WITHOUT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
GROWTH KAMLAGER YOUR- MOTHER
HERE LAYERED HERE HERE HERE
BATES HERE HE'S HERE ATKINS
HERE ATKINS HERE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SO WE WILL START WITH
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES NOT
REQUIRED TO APPEAR IN THIS ITEM
TO. THE THROUGH I- HAPPY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION. MOVED. TO
THE- THANK YOU F. THE RECORD D.
N. E. R. APPOINTMENTS TO THE
ATHLETIC COMMISSION F. IS TO
THE BOARD OF BARBERING AND
COSMETOLOGY G. IS TO THE
BUILDING STANDARDS COMMISSION
H. AND R. I. R. TO THE MINING
AND GEOLOGY BOARD. MADAM
SECRETARY WE CALL THE ROLL.
DROVE HIM WATER HI LONGER I
LAYERED HI THERE I BATES. IF I
HAD TO BUY A CONCERN OR TO ZERO
FORTY ZERO THAT IS DONE I WILL
ENTERTAIN ITEM THREE AND FOUR
OF MEMBERS ARE OKAY THAT WOULD
BE THE REFERRAL OF BILLS AND
THE SESSION SCHEDULED FOR
AUGUST THROUGH SEPTEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. I MOVED THEM BOTH
THANK YOU SENATOR LAYERED-
MADAM SECRETARY WE CALL THE
ROLL. GROWTH AND WATER I AM
LONGER I LAYERED HI. AYE BATES
AYE AYE ATKINS I SIDE OR THE
FEAR FOUR ZERO THAT IS OUT AND
DONE- WE HAVE ONE LAST ITEM
IT'S A RULE WAIVER REQUEST. TO
FROM THE COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC
SAFETY TO WAVE I JOINT RULE
SIXTY ONE TO ALLOW THE
COMMITTEE TO ME TO HEAR BILLS
ON THURSDAY JULY FIFTEENTH
PASSED THE POLICY. FISCAL
COMMITTEES DEADLINE. I WOULD
MOVE THAT. A FROM FROM SENATE
THAT SERVE ON THE PA SAFETY
COULD- SENATOR THANK YOU FOR
MOVING THAT ITEM SO SENATOR COM
LONGER CAN BE HERE ON JULY
FIFTEENTH. YEAH THIS IS GOING
TO BE THREE TO ONE- OF THE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
BOTH KAMLAGER HI RIGHT LATER.
HI FAITH OKAY I ATKINS THAT IS
AND I WITH MY APPRECIATION TO
THE GOOD CENTER FROM LOS
ANGELES FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO
FORTY ZERO THAT IS OUT I
PROMISE YOU IT WILL NOT
CONTINUE LIKE THAT- SO WE ARE
NOW GOING TO MOVE AND JUST FOR
THE PUBLIC RECORD LET ME SHARE
WITH THE PUBLIC THAT WE HAVE TO
MEMBERS ON THIS COMMITTEE ON
RULES THAT ALSO SIT ON BUDGET
COMMITTEE WHICH IS ALSO HAVING
A HEARING AT THIS TIME SO YOU
WILL SEE THEM COME AND GO. I
GUARANTEE YOU THEY'RE
INTERESTED IN THESE
APPOINTMENTS BUT THE CHAIR THAT
WOULD BE ME AND THE VICE CHAIR
WILL OUR WILL CERTAINLY BE VERY
ENGAGED AND THEY WILL BE BACK
AND FORTH SO THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES FOR BEING HERE I
KNOW YOU HAVE TO ESTABLISH A
QUORUM AS WELL IN THE OTHER.
COMMITTEE SO WE WILL NOW TURN
TO GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEES
REQUIRED TO APPEAR. AND WE WILL
START WITH ITEM ONE A. AND THAT
IS THE APPOINTMENT OF SIVA G.
GUNNEDAH AS THE PUBLIC MEMBER
OF THE ENERGY COMMISSION. AND
SO- I'M TRYING TO SEE IF I SEE
THERE HE IS. LET ME SAY
WELCOME- TO YOU THANK YOU FOR
JOINING US. I WOULD LIKE TO
INVITE YOU TO INTRODUCE
YOURSELF ANYONE WITH YOU THAT
YOU WOULD LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE.
N. F. AFTER THOSE INTRODUCTIONS
IN YOUR OPENING COMMENTS WE
WILL GO RIGHT TO MY COLLEAGUES
FOR QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS SO
WELCOME. COMMISSIONER THANK
THANK YOU SO MUCH- GOOD
AFTERNOON HONORABLE CHAIR MICE
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME
AND THE OPPORTUNITY TO APPEAR
IN FRONT OF YOU TODAY. I WOULD
LIKE TO EXTEND MY GRATITUDE TO
YOUR STAFF AND THE APPOINTMENT.
TAX RETIREMENT DOCUMENTS TO MY
CONFIRMATION PROCESS. I WOULD
LIKE TO BRING GOVERNOR NEWSOM
BROWN TRUSTING THAT THIS
IMPORTANT ROLE OF THE ENERGY
COMMISSION. ENERGY COMMISSION
OF THE STATES. POLICY AND
PLANNING AGENCY PLAYS AN
IMPORTANT ROLE. OF CONVENING A
ROBUST DIALOGUE UNTIMELY ENERGY
ISSUES. HELP IDEATE AND OUR
OPTIONS REACHING OUR STATE
SCHOOLS. I'M INCREDIBLY
THANKFUL FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO SERVE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA DURING THIS TIME OF
TRAFFIC TRANSITION. OF HOW WE.
USE ENERGY AND HOW WE'RE GOING
TO SOURCE THAT. I WOULD NOT BE
HERE I DON'T THINK. AND
GENEROSITY OF SO MANY MENTORS
AND- OVER THE YEARS BEGINNING
WITH MY FIRST TEACHING. WITHOUT
IN FIRST ALPHABET CAN CONTINUE
TO BE A SOURCE OF GUIDANCE OVER
THE YEARS. I WANT O EXPRESS MY
GRATITUDE TO MY MOTHER FOR
TIRELESSLY WORKING TO HELP THE
DYSLEXIC KIDS SUCCEED AT
SCHOOL. IN A PLACE AND TIME BUT
IT WAS NOT UNDERSTOOD. I THANK
MY FATHER FROM THE TIME HE
SPENT WITH ME TALKING TO THE
IMPORTANCE OF INTEGRITY. AND
HELPING ME DEVELOP A DEEP
PASSION FOR PUBLIC SERVICE. I
WANT TO THANK ALL MY COLLEAGUES
AT CCC PSE HI SIGN CARD WITHOUT
WHOM MY CONTRIBUTIONS TO DATE
WOULD NOT BE POSSIBLE.
ESPECIALLY TACKLING THE- A
CLEAR LIABILITY ISSUES DURING
EXTREME WEATHER WE EXPERIENCED
LAST YEAR. I WANT THANK MY WIFE
FOR HER LOVE SUPPORT THE DALLAS
YOU TO TAKE ON THE IMPORTANT
ROLE. AND FINALLY TO MY FIVE
YEAR OLD DAUGHTER NORA INTO IT
ON SUNDAY EVEN. BEING SPIED
MEET EVERY COVERAGE COMPASSION
CLARITY THAT THEY NEED TO BRING
TO THE SCHOOL. I TO THE UNITED
OF COURSE MY GOD DEGREE
MECHANICAL. AND HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GO TO SCHOOL IN
UTAH AND WORK IN NEW YORK. FOR
CALLING CALIFORNIA MY HOME FOR
NEARLY TWO DECADES. THE
BEGINNING OF MANAGER CAREER
COINCIDED WITH THE PASSAGE OF
AB TWENTY TWO. LANDMARK
LEGISLATION CALIFORNIA'S
CLIMATE POLICY. IN CALIFORNIA'S
LEGISLATURE HAS ENACTED A
MEMBER OF LOS BUT CONTINUED THE
STATE'S TRADITIONAL SETTING UP
AMBITIOUS CLIMATE GOALS. IF I
DECLINED BECAUSE THIS. FOR
SOMEBODY JUST BEGINNING HIS
CAREER FIFTEEN YEARS AGO THE
VISION THAT CALIFORNIA. IS
SLIDING INTO LEGAL GOING TO BE
A PART OF. AND OPPORTUNITY AND
PRIVILEGE TO WORK IN A NUMBER
OF KEY ISSUES OVER THE LAST
FIFTEEN YEARS. AND MOST
RECENTLY SB ONE HUNDRED AS WELL
AS THE- LIABILITY ISSUES. AS AS
YOU KNOW THE SB ONE HUNDRED
ESTABLISH THE STATE'S QUALITY
TO SERVE. 100% A POLITICALLY
TELLTALE BUT YOU KNOW COUNTRY
SOURCE. I TWENTY TWENTY FORTY
FIVE. OVER THE COURSE OF MY
CAREER I LEARNED IN. OF A
DELIBERATE AND PURSUE COME TO
FOR. OPEN COMPASSION AND- THE
NEW TO LISTEN TO AND CONSIDER
WERE SET UP. COLLABORATION
BUILT ON. TRANSPARENCY AND
RESPECT. TWENTY MILLION IN
LEARNING AND ENSURE THAT INTO.
AND TAKEN ANALYSIS UNDERPINNED.
DECISION MAKING. I THINK AT
LEAST THAT THIS COULD ARE. TO
MAKE GOOD POLICY AND I'M DEEPLY
TO AND THAT THEY CONTINUE TO
CUT MY WORK. I RECOGNIZE THAT
THE MUCH NEEDED TRANSITION TO
CLEAN ENERGY ECONOMY WILL BE
CHALLENGING AND REQUIRE
DIFFICULT DECISIONS. TO ENSURE
THAT NO CALIFORNIANS ARE LEFT
BEHIND. AND ASSIGNED LEAD ON
ENERGY LIABILITY ASSESSMENTS IN
SB ONE HUNDRED. I WILL WORK
DILIGENTLY TO INCLUDE
PROCEDURAL EQUITY FOR ALL
STAKEHOLDERS CONTINUE TO
MODERNIZE THE DATA ANALYSIS
MAX'S. AND ENSURE THAT THE
ASSESSMENTS CONTINUE TO THE
BLOG TO SUPPORT DECISION MAKING
THAT IS ROBUST. AND ADDRESSES
THE NEED FOR THE NEXT TWENTY
FIVE YEARS. THANK YOU AGAIN SO
MUCH FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO BE
HERE TODAY. AND I'M LOOK
FORWARD TO TAKE YOUR QUESTIONS.
SURE THANK YOU VERY. I
APPRECIATE THAT- I MISSED HOW
OLD YOUR SON. THREE TO TWO TWO
GOT IT- LET ME ARE ASK MADAM
VICE CHAIR IF YOU WANT TO GO
AHEAD AND START GIVEN THAT IT'S
YOU AND ME AND- WE CAN WE CAN
GET THIS DONE. THANK YOU YEAH
THANK YOU. COMMISSIONER I'M
GONNA MAKE SURE I'M SAYING YOUR
NAME PROPERLY LINDA IS THAT
CORRECT YEAH SECONDLY
DEVELOPMENT THEY ARE NOW LIVING
COMPLIMENTS YOU ON WHICH WHAT
IS A VERY INSPIRING STORY
COMING INTO OUR COUNTRY AND A
BEING DYSLEXIC CERTAINLY- I
HAVE A CERTAIN A COIN FOR THE
FRANCE AND I THINK MY SON AT
THE BEGINNING MIGHT HAVE A
LITTLE PROBLEM WITH THAT
BECAUSE IT IS SOMETHING THAT IS
STILL HIDDEN. IN A FULL
INTERRUPTS AND EDUCATION AND
YOURS IS QUITE REMARKABLE FILL
A KUDOS TO YOUR MOM AND ALL THE
MOM SAID ALL OF US FOR MOM SAY
YEA TO OUR SON SO. THAT THE
THREE AWFUL WHICH WAS A VERY
IMPRESSIVE AND THERE ARE-
BIOGRAPHY RESUME IS THAT YOU
HAVE ALL GREAT SUPPORT FROM THE
INDUSTRY THAT YOU ARE. NEEDING
TO WORK WITH AND NOT FOUND TO
BE LIKE YOU'VE ALREADY
DEVELOPED A PRETTY STRONG
PARTNERSHIP THERE AND HAVING AN
OPEN MIND AND BEING ON ENGAGED
IN DISCUSSIONS ON HOW WE'RE
GOING TO MEET THESE VERY ALL OF
THEM DISHES SCHOOLS ARE NEEDED
GOALS AS E LOOK AT CLIMATE
CHANGE SO. LET ME JUMP INTO MY
I'VE JUST HAD TWO QUESTIONS IN
TWO AREAS. ONE IS THE ARM. THE
ABILITY TO MEET THOSE TWENTY
FOUR FIVE FOR. WITH THE PHONE
THE I. BECAUSE I'VE BEEN MANAGE
A TRIP THE SIZE OF OUR- THAT
LACKED CITY. READ AND I'M
WONDERING WE HAVE ANY REPORTS
YET THAT GIVE US AN IDEA OF HOW
MUCH ELECTRICITY WE'RE GOING TO
NEED TO POWER. YOU KNOW
EVERYTHING ELECTRIC CAR CARS OR
TRUCKS TRANSPORTATION- ARENA
AND IT. THE IDEA THAT THAT
COULD BE ACCOMPLISHED WITHIN.
WHAT I CONSIDER TO BE KIND OF A
SHORT PERIOD OF TIME WITHIN
FOURTEEN. PLUS YEARS OF FULL IF
YOU COULD. GIVE US SOME IDEA OF
YOUR CONCERNS IN THAT AREA
YOU'RE BOTH IN THAT AREA AND
WHAT THE PATHWAY TO SUCCESS.
NOW IT IS GOING TO BE AND IT
WILL CERTAINLY AND PERHAPS
NEED. MORE SUPPORT FROM YOUR
LEGISLATORS. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR DESPITE THE QUESTION
SENATOR AND THANK YOU FOR
RECOGNIZING MY MOM AS WELL
THANK YOU CAN CRITICAL TOWARD.
SPECIFICALLY TO YOUR QUESTION
ON THE SB ONE HUNDRED AND OUT
OF THIS AND I WANT TO TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO. COMMENDED THE-
COLLABORATION BETWEEN CARB USE
TNCS THE ENVELOPING THE JOINT
SUPPORT. IT WAS PUBLISHED
EARLIER THIS YEAR AND WE WILL
MAKE SURE THAT THE RECORD IS
SENT TO YOUR OFFICE. SO WE DO
HAVE- HIGH LEVEL AND NUMBERS ON
YOU KNOW WHAT DISEASE ARE STILL
QUITE MONTHS WOULD BE. AND YOU
MENTIONED I WILL BE LOOKING AT
TRIPLING AND POTENTIALLY EVEN
QUADRUPLING. OF AGREED BY
TWENTY FORTY FIVE OVER THE NEXT
TWENTY FIVE YEARS. SO SOME OF
THE KEY ELEMENTS OF THAT- ISN'T
ON THE KEY TAKE AWAYS WE GOT
FROM THEM WAS STICKING AGREE
FEASIBLE- BUT IT ALSO REQUIRES
AN INCREDIBLE AMOUNT OF EFFORT
TO ENSURING THAT THE STEVEN THE
GROUND HAPPENS. I WE LOOKED AT
SOME OF THAT- OPPORTUNITIES TO
DIE BUT COULD YOU PLEASE
SOURCES AND- MODELING A SHORT
BREAK OVER. AND THEN THE
RESOURCE DIVERSE CITY IS THAT
BETTING WHILE I'M DOWN YOU'D
INCLUDING THE GEOGRAPHIC- I
DIVERSE CITY HAVE BEEN PUTTING
ENERGY. OPTION WITH OPTIONS AND
AS WELL AS UNDERSTATEMENT. SO
IN TERMS OF SPECIFIC- SPECIFIC
THINGS YOU KNOW WE LOOKED AT-
I'M. STATE THE IMPORTANCE OF.
D. OVERALL OUR DATA STORAGE.
AND BUT LOOKING AT ALL AT SIXTY
TIME TO BUILD A CO MEANT ABOUT
STORAGE. LOOKING AT ABOUT
TRIPLING THE SIZE OF. AND
DISORDER WIND SO TAKING ALL
INTO. AS KNOW WHAT IT'S AN
INCREDIBLE CHAO. TO BE ABLE TO
MAKE SURE- WE GET THEIR- ARE
THE I THINK YOU. NO WHICH OVER
THE PRO. OF THE- THIS CALL.
TAKING STEPS AND IT'S TO TALK.
LEVEL AND HOW- GIGAWATT OF NEW
ENERGY SOURCE. TO GET TO TWENTY
AND I THINK THIS WILL COUNTY TO
THAT UP. I'M AS WE GO. I'M LIKE
I'M NOT SURE I'M CONVENE WE'RE
GOING TO THE GOAL THAT I IT'S
ITS IMPORTANT HAVE A GO AND
THEN ELSEWHERE CLOSE AND CLOSER
ON CERTAINLY THE- BILL WHO ARE
THE F. IN THE IN THE- THE-
PARTICULAR ARENA- LIKE YOURS.
WILL BE ABLE TO GIVE GARDEN AS
WERE APPROACH. I THINK SOME.
BECAUSE OF WERE NOT. YOU KNOW
WE'RE NOT GETTING THAT CLOSE IN
FIVE YEARS SOME NEW DIRECTIVE
NEEDS TO BE DISCUSSED AND
CERTAINLY SOME OF THAT BROUGHT
BACK TO THIS LEGISLATURE. THE
AREA THAT OF CONCERNING TO ME
AND I'LL GIVE YOU JUST A QUICK
BACKGROUND. I THINK IT WAS IN
THE FORTIES OR THE FIFTIES I
JUST HEARD MY PARENTS TALKING
ABOU. THE FACT THAT EVERYBODY
WAS LOOKING AT AN ALL ELECTRIC
HOME THAT WAS KIND OF A BIG. A
BIG THING IF YOU WERE. IN THAT
AGE RANGE WHERE YOU'RE GOING TO
BE ABLE TO BUY A HOME. AND MY
PARENTS I THINK WE'RE
APPROACHING THAT. AND DECIDED
THAT OUT OF THE DIDN'T WALK OUT
BECAUSE OF STUDIES THAT MIGHT
BE A GOOD IDEA AT THE TIME I'M
ASSUMING BECAUSE OF THE STORIES
I WAS HEARING. WAS THAT IT WAS
GOING TO BE TOO EXPENSIVE SO
THEY OPTED FOR GAS OR NATURAL
GAS. SO NOW WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
ON NOW WE'RE GOING TO TOTAL.
DIFFERENT DIRECTION BECAUSE
HOME BUILDERS I THINK WE'RE
STARTING TO NOT REQUIRE THAT
ARE PUT THAT IN MANY OF THEIR
HOMES. THEY WEREN'T SELLING FOR
THAT VERY REASON. FOR NOW WE'RE
GOING THE OPPOSITE DIRECTION
GOING BACK TO ALL ELECTRICITY
IN THE HOMES AND GETTING RID OF
ALL THE NATURAL GAS. AND I AM
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THAT THAT
IF WE DO HAVE. BLACKOUTS WE DO
HAVE. YOU KNOW THE DIFFICULTY
OF REACHING THE GOAL BUILDING
THE GREAT BIG ENOUGH TO
ACCOMMODATE ALL THIS GOING TO
BE DEPENDENT ON IT. IF WE
ELIMINATE GAS COMPLETELY. OF
WHAT WILL HAPPEN THEN IS THAT
IS THAT A GOOD POLICY TO
IMMEDIATELY BE SAYING WE HAVE
TO YOU KNOW REMOVE THAT AT THIS
POINT IN TIME WITHOUT ANY REAL
STUDY SHOWING US HOW MUCH WE'RE
GOING TO NEED AND WHETHER WE
CAN ACCOMPLISH THAT IN THE TIME
THAT'S BEEN GIVEN THROUGH A
VERY AS PIECE OF THE
LEGISLATION. I THANK YOU AGAIN
SENATOR ASKED THE BOARD FOR THE
CLEAN PARKING QUESTION AND I
JUST WANNA TAKE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SHARE. AT A VERY HIGH LEVEL
OF THAT YOU KNOW AS AS WE
LOOKED AT- OF SEVERAL PATHWAYS.
FOR REACHING OUR CLIMATE GOALS.
IT IS. IT IS KIND OF AGREED
UPON- BROAD CONSENSUS NOT. TO
HAVE AN IDEA OF ANALYTICAL
WORK. ON THAT YEAH LIKE TO
VACATION OF BUILDINGS. AND THE
SPECIFICALLY DEFINITION AND
COMMERCIAL AS WELL AS THE
ELECTRIFICATION OF LIGHT DUTY.
VEHICLES IS THE MOST COST
EFFECTIVE PATHWAY TO
DECARBONIZING OUR ECONOMY. I'M
SO AND AS YOU NOTED I THINK YOU
KNOW THAT THANKS MOST OF THE-
WORK THAT THE AGENCIES ARE
COLLECTIVELY DOING- IS
BASICALLY UNDERPINNED BY THAT
ANALYSIS THAT THE EDUCATION. IS
AN IMPORTANT PATHWAY. I DO ALSO
NOTED IN A THERE'S A NUMBER OF
THINGS WE NEED TO BE VERY
THOUGHTFUL AND MINDFUL ABOUT.
YOU KNOW HOW DESPERATE THE
CHANGE AND THE DEMAND PATTERNS.
FOR EXAMPLE HOW MUCH OF THAT
INCREASE BUT ALSO HOW MUCH OF
THE- IMPACT DURING THE PEAK
TIMES. PARTICULARLY ON THE GAS
SIDE AS YOU INCREASE THE AMOUNT
OF ELECTRIFICATION. WHAT DOES
THAT DO YOU- IN TERMS OF A GAS
USAGE. BOTH BOTH ADDRESS SYSTEM
LEVEL BUT ALSO AT A LOCAL LEVEL
SO THESE ARE IMPORTANT
QUESTIONS THAT ASK IF HE'S HE'S
REALLY TRYING TO TACKLE THIS
YEAR IN THE AYE PROCESS.
UNIMPORTANT FUNCTION OF THE CC
IS TO. ENSURE THAT WE HAVE AN
UNDERPINNING ANALYTICAL
UNDERPINNING FOR THE STATE AND
OUT OF THE NECESSARY OPTIONS TO
THINK THROUGH THIS GOAL
BUCKLEY. SO IN THIS AYE BURKE-
WE ARE LOOKING AT THE ANALYSIS
WERE BUILDING DECARBONIZATION.
I'M AS WELL AS TRANSPORTATION
AS WELL AS NATURAL GAS AS A
WHOLE. LOOKING AT WHAT WHAT IS
THE DIFFERENT- DEMAND FUTURES
COULD LOOK LIKE AND WHAT DOES
THAT MEAN I'VE COME A COUPLE
EXTEND POINT- AS WELL AS
RELIABILITY STANDPOINT. AND
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE ARE
ACTIVELY THINKING TO AND WHAT
ABSOLUTELY MAKE SURE WE WORK
WITH YOUR- OFFICE AND. AND KEEP
YOU UPDATED ON I'M NOT
ANNOUNCES. THANK YOU FOR THAT I
THINK OF REAL IMPORT THAT. YOU
DEEPER DE INTO ROOMS OF. HAVING
NOT LEAVE FOR BACK ON. IN THE
OF THE OF ARE NOT BEING ABLE TO
PROVIDE THE ELECT. OF GOING TO
BE RIGHT. A SO MANY SECTORS. SO
I JUST THOUGHT THAT I TO YOU A
CHILD. SHE'S ON THAT BOARD. TO
LOSE OF THAT ON DURING SOME OF
BLACK OUT THAT. I'VE SUFFERED
THERE MY FAMILY SUFFERED OVER
YEARS AND NOT BECAUSE IT WAS
NEVER BECAUSE OF THE HUGE
DEMAND. ON THE GRID AT THAT
TIME IT WAS NOT DURING THE BE
VERY WARM WEATHER THAT WAS
WHEN. THEY WERE DIGGING NEW
PIPES OR DEVELOPMENTS AND-
ACTUALLY RAN INTO LINES UNDER
THE- UNDER THE HIGHWAYS THAT
CUT ELECTRICITY TO MY HOME. A
COUPLE TIMES I DURING THE
DEVELOP A LEGAL YEARS IN SOUTH
ORANGE COUNTY WHERE I LIVE. AND
WE HAD GAS GAS STOVE AND A GAS
DRYER SIMPLE I COULD CONTINUE
TO COOK. BY CANDLELIGHT AND
I'LL CERTAINLY WASH A FEW
CLOTHES AND PUT HIM IN A DRYER
SO THAT MY KIDS HAVE SOMETHING
TO WEAR THE NEXT DAY AND- THE
OTHER THINGS THAT ARE JUST YOU
KNOW EVERYDAY. LITTLE THINGS
THAT YOU A COMEDY BUT WHEN
THERE'S NOT ANOTHER OPTION-
THIS IS NOT GOING TO BE GOOD
FOR. CALIFORNIANS AND CERTAINLY
FOR FAMILIES. AND ALL OF US IN
PARTICULAR SO- IT'S VERY VERY
IMPORTANT TO LOOK AT. SOMETHING
THAT THE FAIL SAFE- FOR THE
ENERGY NEEDS THAT WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE THAT. THANK YOU ARE
BEGAN FOR YOUR COMMITMENT TO
THIS VERY VERY IMPORTANT TO US.
WELL YOU'RE GOING TO PLAY FOR
US HERE IN CALIFORNIA. WE
SHOULD THE BATH AND CERTAINLY
YOU'LL HAVE MY SUPPORT. AT THE-
APPROPRIATE TIME. THANK YOU
MADAM VICE. TOM AND I
APPRECIATE YOUR GETTING STARTED
ON THOSE QUESTIONS I JUST WANT
TO CHECK IN ON A COUPLE OF
ITEMS BECAUSE I THINK I IT'S
ALSO GOOD FOR THE PUBLIC TO GET
TO HEAR SOME OF THIS- IN THIS
FORUM- AND I KNOW. ABOUT YOUR
EXTENSIVE HISTORY AND SERVICE
AND SO- YOU OBVIOUSLY MORE THAN
HIT THE GROUND RUNNING AS YOU.
YOU WERE APPOINTED TO THIS
ROLE. I WANTED TO CHECK IN ON
OFF SHORE WIND POWER- AND JUST
KIND OF GET YOUR- THOUGHTS ON.
A FEW THINGS- WE ALL KNOW THAT
IT HOLDS A GREAT DEAL OF
PROMISES A TOOL TO HELP
CALIFORNIA MEET ITS CLEAN
ENERGY GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION
TARGETS. I KNOW THAT THE CEC'S
BEEN HOLDING PROCEEDINGS ON THE
BENEFITS AND THE BARRIERS OF
DEVELOPMENT. I JUST WANT TO ASK
YOU YOUR THOUGHTS ON-AS THE
WORKSHOPS ARE CONCLUDED. ON
THIS TOPIC WHAT DO YOU
ANTICIPATE THE NEXT STEPS TO
BE. AND DO YOU THINK THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD CONSIDER.
ESTABLISHING A ONE TOP STOP
SHOP PERMITTING PROCESS FOR OFF
SHORE WIND POWER SIMILAR TO
WHAT THE COMMISSION NOW DOES.
FOR THERMAL POWER PLANTS ARE
JUST YOUR THOUGHTS ON THAT
OVERALL. YEAH AND AT THANK YOU-
CHAIR AND I THINK I JUST WANNA-
I START BY. TAKING A HIGH LEVEL
VIEW ON JUST THE OPPORTUNITY
FOR THE OPTIONAL WIND. AND HAS
DONE IT SENATORS BASED KIND OF
RAISED AND THE DSP ONE HUNDRED.
WHEN WE LOOK AT THE DIVERSE
CITY OF RESOURCES AS WE MARCH
TOWARDS A CLEAN ENERGY GOALS
TWENTY FORTY FIVE. I WE WERE
ABLE TO PUT IN ABOUT TEN
GIGABYTES OF AVAILABLE
RESOURCES BASED ON. WHAT WE
THINK IS THAT IS A DECENT
ESTIMATE AT TAKING THE CENTRAL
COAST AND THAT AND ALL CORDS.
IN TERMS OF THE AVAILABILITY
AND ALL TEN GIGAWATTS OF
OFFSHORE WIND WAS WAS TAKEN AT
THE KEY RESOURCE STACK- IN OUR
MODELING HOLDING TO. THE
COMPLEMENTARY LOW CHANCE OF THE
COMPLEMENTARY GENERATION
PROFILE BUT IT HAD AS WELL AS
CONTINUING COST DECLINES. SO I
THINK IT IS ONE OF THE OTHERS
OPTION WOULDN'T HAVE AN
INCREDIBLE OPPORTUNITY. TO BE A
PART OF OUR SOLUTION AS WE MOVE
FORWARD IN ENSURING. THAT WE
NEED TO TWENTY FORTY FIVE GOALS
OF A ZERO CARBON. RESOURCES TO
BE- IN. OF PERMITTING AND THE
BROADER CONGRESS- AT. ACTUALLY
AT THIS IS JUST SOMETHING THAT
I DO KNOW NEED FOR TO COME. I
LED BY COMING DOUGLAS. AND I
HAVE BEEN- ACCORDING TO. NOT
BECOME AWARE OF SOME THE-
CONGRESS GOING ON AT THE BILL
CITY HIGH. ABOUT KNOCKING THE
AT TO. IN DE PASSED TO HER
UNDERSTAND. AND THINKING ON THE
SUBJECT. SO I WOULD LIKE TO AS
REQUEST PERMISSION TO FOLLOW UP
WITH YOU ABOUT. I ON ON BECAUSE-
I THINK FROM MY PURSE. I THINK
OPTION BUT HE IMPORTANT I THINK
HAVING STREAMLINED PROCESS
THESE IN ENSURING. THAT
OFFSHORE WIND HAS A TIMELY.
AFTER MEETING AS WELL AS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO BECOME THE
RESOURCE ACTIVITIES INCREDIBLY.
IMPORTANT LOOKING FORWARD.
THANK YOU HI APPRECIATE THAT
AND I CERTAINLY COULD FALL UP.
COMMISSIONER DOUGLAS IS. OUR
AND I SHOULD PROBABLY LOOK BACK
AND SEE WHAT YOU ARE LEAD
COMMISSIONER ON ICY- BECAUSE I
MOSTLY HAD- SOME GENERAL
QUESTIONS I WANTED TO. I WANTED
TO ASK YOU IF YOU WANT TO
COMMENT ON IT AGAIN IF IT'S IF
YOU'RE NOT THE LEAD ON THIS BUT
IF YOU WHATEVER YOU ADD I
APPRECIATE. THE ELECTRIC
PROGRAM INVESTMENT CHARGE ARE
EPIC PROGRAM AS WE CALL IT. I
WANTED TO- YOU KNOW WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT INVESTMENTS IN ENERGY
RESEARCH CERTAINLY. ARE TO
CLEAN OUR ARE GREETED REDUCE
CONSUMER COSTS BUT IT SEEMS A
FEW IN THE LEGISLATURE ARE EVER
WELL THAT IT SEEMS THAT FEW OF
US ARE AWARE OF THE PROGRAM.
AND ITS BENEFITS A SO I
WONDERED IF YOU HAD ANY
THOUGHTS ABOUT HOW THE FUNDS
ARE CURRENTLY BEING SPENT. ON
ARE THEY SAVING RATEPAYERS
MONEY AND DELIVERING ON CLEAN
ENERGY. AND FROM YOUR
PERSPECTIVE WHERE WOULD YOU
LIKE TO SEE THIS THE PROGRAM
DOLLARS INVESTED ARE THERE NEW
OR EMERGING TECHNOLOGIES JUST
HOW LEVEL THOUGHTS ON THAT TO
NOT YOU DON'T HAVE TO GET INTO
THE- TO THE WEEDS. ACTUALLY AND-
I THINK AGAIN I'M NOT BELIEVE.
COMMISSIONER ON THIS ISSUE.
PADGETT HKE SHIELD AND CAN
COMMISSION MCALLISTER I NEED TO
HAVE A PROGRAM FOR THE CC. BUT
FROM MY VANTAGE POINT I THINK
COMMITTEE THE R. AND D. FOR
CLEAN ENERGY IS A LITTLE MORE
MORE IMPORTANT THAN EVER I'M
LOOKING FORWARD AB MARCHING
TOWARDS THE TWENTY FORTY FIVE
GOALS. ESPECIALLY THE SEARCH-
IN IN AND CLEAN THE OPENING UP
THE OPPORTUNITY OF DEMAND
RESPONSE. DISTRIBUTED ENERGY
RESOURCES A LONG DURATION
STORAGE ARE VITAL FOR THE
FUTURE OF CALIFORNIA. FINALLY
THINK THROUGH THE LIABILITY AS
WELL AS ABORIGINAL TWENTY FORTY
FIVE GOALS. IN MIND MY HIGH
LEVEL UNDERSTANDING OF THE
PROGRAM AND YOU KNOW FROM THE
VANTAGE POINT AND JUST
BEGINNING TO LEARN ABOUT. IS
YOU KNOW WE HAVE BEEN ABLE TO.
INVEST IN SUCH IMPORTANT
TECHNOLOGIES- THAT IF NOT FOR
OUR SPECIES. I INVESTMENT AS IT
GREW UP TO A PART OF THE
PROCESS. YOU KNOW WE HAVEN'T.
BUT TO IGNITE. HAVEN'T BEEN
ABLE TO ACCOMPLISH SOME OF THE-
OPPORTUNITIES THAT WE SEE ON
THE DEMAND RESPONSE EXAMPLE OF
PIECE. INVESTMENT DEMENTIA.
ABOUT MILLION GRANT TO ALBION
NOW IS THE ONE OF THOSE THINGS
WHICH BE IN THE- ACTUAL
PROMISED AND I'M- THE- PASSED
WITH THE SPECIFIC BENEFITS OF
THE- I WOULD TO FOLLOW UP WITH
YOU DO PROVIDE SPECIFIC. THANK
YOU COMMISSIONER- I THINK IAN
MAYBE THEY'LL- THING I WOULD
BRING UP AND THIS GUY CAME UP
FROM ONE OF MY COLLEAGUES ARE
ON ONE OF OUR- CAUCUS CALLS OUR
CONCERNS ABOUT CYBER SECURITY.
AND CLEARLY YOU KNOW OUR
ABILITY TO PARTNER AS YOU
REFERENCED- IN YOUR RESPONSES.
OUT WITH FEDERAL AGENCIES AND
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE ENTITIES ON
CYBER SECURITY. EXERCISES
PRACTICED GENERAL PREPAREDNESS.
WHAT WHAT IS THE COMMISSION'S
ROLE AND LEVEL OF INVOLVEMENT
IN PROTECTING OUR ENERGY
INFRASTRUCTURE AGAINST CYBER
SECURITY THREATS I THINK WE'VE
ALL HEARD A COUPLE OF EXAMPLES.
WHERE THIS IS BEEN A PROBLEM.
IN RECENT YEARS AND JUST AGAIN
YOUR HIGH LEVEL. THOUGHTS ON
THIS AND- AT SOME POINT I KNOW
A NUMBER MY COLLEAGUES. GROWING
INCREASINGLY CONCERNED ABOUT
THE ISSUE. THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION AND I JUST WANNA KNOW
TO THE VERY TOP IN MY VIEW A
CYBER SECURITY THE DEALS THAT
TO AN ENERGY INFRASTRUCTURE IN
THE U. S. ECONOMY. I'M THAT
PART FROM THAT POTENTIAL
PHYSICAL ATTACKS YOU MIGHT BE
ON THE GRID INFRASTRUCTURE I'M
DEAD THE CHROMATIC ACTIONS ARE
LIKE A SOLAR STORMS ARE
POTENTIALLY ANY AND P. AND THE
OTHER REAL BIG THAT IS. THE
CYBER OF CYBER ATTACKS. SUCH
I'M GOING TO GET A- OF. AS YOU.
AND IT HAS TO. DO YOU EXECUTIVE
ORDER BY GOVERNOR. I WOULD
REALLY AT. TO CALIFORNIA'S
SECURITY INTEGRATION CENTER.
AND GET ANY OVERSEAS ARE ARE
KIND OF WORK. IN THE SECURITY.
TO THE ENERGY COMMISSION- PAST
THAT THE CENTRAL DATA
REPOSITORY FOR STATE I THINK IN
TERMS OF DATA. ENERGY DATA WE
HAVE A FUNCTION IN ENSURING
THAT WE PROVIDE A DATA TO. A
BOAT OUT CELTIC AS WELL AS
CATTLE YES WE DO NOT SUPPORT
FUNCTIONS. I'M SO TO SUPPORT
FUNCTION EIGHTEEN I
SPECIFICALLY ON PAPER SECURITY.
AND WHAT WE DO AND THAT IS
PROVIDE DATA THAT WE HAVE TO
PROVIDE POPULAR SHIP. ON ON
SPECIFIC ISSUES THAT MIGHT
EMERGE AND THAT'S THAT'S THE
EXTENDED SPEAKING BOOKS ON
THAT. BUT WE CONTINUE TO
CLOSELY MONITOR. AND WORK WITH
A CALORIE. THANK YOU WELL THOSE
ARE QUESTIONS- I WOULD-
COMMISSION JUST SAY AS OUR
COLLEAGUES COME BACK SENATOR
LAYERED IN PALM LONGER. THEY
MAY WANT TO MAKE COMMENTS OR
ASK A QUESTION BUT WHAT I'M
GONNA DO RIGHT NOW IS GO AHEAD
AND GO TO PUBLIC COMMENT- AND-
WE'LL START RIGHT HERE IN ROOM
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE BATTLE
ABOUT THE WAY I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR EXPERTISE. IT
IT'S CLEAR TO ME FROM THE
RESPONSES IN YOUR WORK PRIOR
TO. BEING APPOINTED A
COMMISSIONER THAT- WE ARE
FORTUNATE I BELIEVE TO HAVE
SOMEONE OF YOUR EXPERTISE AND
SO I WANT TO- AGREE WITH THE
COMMENTS. MADE BY MY VICE CHAIR
IS WE STARTED THIS- PROCEEDING
AND JUST ACKNOWLEDGE THAT. I WE
ARE A LARGE STATE WERE A BIG
PART OF THE WESTERN. GRID AND-
FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE
WORLD AND- YOU KNOW IT'S
CRITICAL FOR US THOSE OF US WHO
DON'T HAVE YOUR EXPERTISE TO BE
ABLE TO COUNT ON. WHAT YOU KNOW
WHEN AND HOW YOU WORK AND PULL
THESE ISSUES TOGETHER BETWEEN
THE- ENERGY COMMISSION THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD CAL AYE SO. THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION ARE
ALL INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT I
ENTITIES THAT REALLY. HOLD THE
FATE OF ALMOST FORTY MILLION
PEOPLE IN OUR STATE SO I WANT
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT. AS WE ARE
GO TO PUBLIC COMMENT. WE'RE
GONNA START RIGHT HERE IN ROOM
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE- WITH
WITNESSES. WHO MAY BE IN
SUPPORT WELL WHO ARE IN SUPPORT
WERE STARTING WITH SUPPORT- LET
ME SEE IF THEY'RE MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC HERE. I DON'T SEE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC THAT ARE
PRESENT IN ROOM THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE SO I'M GOING TO LOOK
AT ROOM ONE TWELVE WE HAVE A
SECOND ROOM. WHO WANT TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT I DON'T SEE
ANYBODY SERVE APPROACHING THE
DYESS. SO I'M GONNA GO AHEAD
AND TURN TO OUR TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE. AND WELCOME OUR
MODERATOR AND IF YOU WOULD-
PREPARED A PROMPT INDIVIDUALS
LET ME JUST SAY TO THOSE WHO
WILL BE SPEAKING TO THE
WITNESSES. WERE GONNA ASK THAT
WHEN YOU SPEAK. PLEASE PROVIDE
YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION IF ANY
YOU REPRESENT AND POSITION ON
THE APPOINTMENT. AND AGAIN ON
BEHALF OF OUR COURT REPORTER I
WOULD ASK THAT YOU SPEAK SLOWLY
AND CLEARLY AND WITH THAT
MODERATOR WELCOME. THANK YOU
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE CURRENTLY HAVE FIVE IN
Q. WHAT ABOUT WHAT LINE NUMBER
EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN.
WELCOME MEMBERS THANK YOU. I'LL
TRY AND ON BEHALF OF AMERICAN
GREENPOWER CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND IN
STRONG SUPPORT COMMISSIONER
DURING THE CONFIRMATION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
WITNESS. LINE TWELVE YOUR LINE
IS NOW OPEN. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS ENTRY ENTRY
HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF ALL
BANDS ENERGY ECONOMY- STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NINE TWENTY
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. NUMBER
TEN AND NUMBER GARY NUMAN
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY EFFICIENCY AND DEMAND
MANAGEMENT COUNCIL WELCOME
TRANSPORT. THANK YOU SO MUCH
NEXT WITNESS. ONE FOURTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. NUMBER TWO-
MEMBERS OF THE CANADIAN MINING
NAMES ARE TO STOCK FROM THE
PEOPLE REGULATORY LAUGHLIN
ENERGY I HAVE THE GREAT
PLEASURE OF SEEING NOW
COMMISSIONER GOING BERSERK
SOCIALLY NAVIGATE MANY CHARGES
PROSPECTIVE. ALWAYS LOOKING
INTELLIGENCE GREAT EXPERTISE
COMPASSION AND GRACE I'M
CONFIDENT THAT IF CONFIRMED
COMMISSIONER GRAHAM IS A PLAN
THAT WILL BE CONSIDERED ONE OF
THE VERY BEST IN. THE HISTORY
OF THE ENERGY COMMISSION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT
WITNESS. LINE TWENTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS PATRICK WELCH WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL UTILITIES
ASSOCIATION AND WE SUPPORT THE
NOMINATION AND APPOINTMENT OF
PRESSURE GOING TO AND- DRIVE
OUT THANK YOU. THANKS VERY MUCH
OTHER WITNESSES MADAME
MODERATOR. YES MA'AM ONE
NINETEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO THIS IS JANET GANYAN AND
I AM REPRESENTING THE BLUE LAKE
RANCHERIA TRIBE WHICH IS A
FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED NATIVE
AMERICAN TRIBE IN FAR NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA. AND WE ARE JUST
CALLING IN- IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF COMMISSIONER GLINDA-
CERTAINLY AS WE TRANSITION TO
OUR TO CARBONIZED CREATED- AND
SOME OF THE DISCUSSION- THAT
HAS BEEN HELD HERE EARLIER
POINTS TO THE CHALLENGES AND
OPPORTUNITIES THERE. THAT
COMMISSION COMMISSIONER GOOD
DOES THE EXPERTISE AND
EXPERIENCE- SEVEN MECHANICAL
ENGINEER- IN DEMAND ANALYSIS-
AND HIS OTHER ROLES IN THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION-
GET REALLY POSITIONED HIM SO
WELL- FOR THIS ROLE AND IN
ADDITION I WILL SAY THAT HAVE
ALREADY HAD THE PLEASURE OF
WORKING WITH COMMISSIONER
GUNDA. ON THE DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES ADVISORY GROUP- AND
WE'VE ALREADY STARTED TO SORT
OF ROLL UP OUR SLEEVES AND GET
TO WORK THERE SO STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS. ONE
SEVENTEEN YEAR LINE IS OPEN.
BUT IT IS JUST A CHANCE BUT THE
JONES WITH THE INDEPENDENT
ENERGY PRODUCERS ASSOCIATION
AND- WE TO- SUPPORT- THE
APPOINTMENT OF MR MELINDA- YOU
SOME LEVEL HEADED LISTENS WELL
WHICH IS ESSENTIAL IN THE
ENERGY SECTOR AND I THINK HE'S
SHOWN GREAT LEADERSHIP AND BOTH
THE S. B. ONE HUNDRED REPORT AS
WELL AS THE IMPORT WORKING
CURRENTLY UNDERTAKING- WITH
RESPECT TO- THE LIABILITY. AND
I CANNOT UNDERSCORE THE
IMPORTANCE OF HAVING SOMEONE
WHO IS LEVEL HEADED LEADING- IN
EFFORTS WHICH RESPECT TO
BEIJING RELIABILITY SO WE
WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT IS-
APPOINTMENT AND WE WERE THERE
TONIGHT THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NEXT WITNESS. BEFORE
WE OPEN UP OUR LAST LINE WHICH
IS NUMBER FIFTEEN AS A REMINDER
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK OF THE PART OF MR
GOING TO PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. WHY FIFTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MADAM PRO TEM
SENATORS SMART RALPH CABANA
ENERGY CO DIRECTOR FOR THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL. I'M SPEAKING TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF THE NOMINATION FOR
NRDC BUT I CAN SENSE ALSO THE-
APPROVING PRESENCE OF THE
ENTIRE EXTENDED FAMILY. OF THE
UC DAVIS ENERGY AND EFFICIENCY
INSTITUTE. CALIFORNIA NEEDS
ENERGY REGULATORS WHO COMBINED
EXTENSIVE EXPERTISE. WITH A
PASSION AND DETERMINATION TO
OVERCOME EVERY BARRIER TO
DECARBONIZE THE ECONOMY. WHILE
ENSURING AFFORDABLE AND
RELIABLE ENERGY SERVICES FOR
ALL. COMMISSIONER GOING TO. FIX
THAT BOWLED SUPERBLY AND WE ARE
CHEN AYE VOTE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAME MODERATOR
DID ANYONE ELSE STYLE IN. NO
ONE ELSE HAS SHOWN SUPPORT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'LL BE
BACK WITH YOU MOMENTARILY. OKAY
HAVEN'T HEARD FROM SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
THOSE WHO MIGHT BE IN
OPPOSITION AND WE WILL START
AGAIN BACK HERE IN ROOM THIRTY
ONE NINETY ONE. AND AGAIN I
DON'T SEE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
THAT ARE PRESENT ARE TO
TESTIFY. IN THIRTY ONE NINETY
ONE I AM LOOKING AT ROOM ONE
TWELVE TILL NO ONE HAS- STEP
FORWARD THERE SO MANY MODERATOR
WE ARE ALREADY BACK UP WITH%
YOU. AND LET ME JUST SAY FOR
THOSE WHO WANT TO CALL IN AGAIN
OUR NUMBER IS EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN. TWO TWO SIX EIGHT ONE
EIGHT NINE AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS TWO EIGHT SEVEN SIX ZERO
FIVE NINE. AND AGAIN I WOULD
SAY YOUR NAME ORGANIZATION IF
ANY AND YOUR SUPPORT AGAIN
SPEAK SLOWLY AND CLEARLY AS
THOSE INCREDIBLE MEMBERS WHO
CALLED IN SUPPORT DID-
EXCELLENT ROLE MODELS TO SPEAK
SLOWLY AND CLEARLY. MADAME
MODERATOR- I'M TURNING IT BACK
OVER TO YOU. OPPOSITION FOR
OBVIOUSLY. THANK YOU LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WOULD BE IN
OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THE TIME. AND I
DON'T KNOW ONE OF HOUSING.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MATTER
MODERATOR I'M SURE WE'LL TALK
TO YOU IN A COUPLE MORE MINUTES
FROM NOW- WITH THAT I'M GONNA
COME BACK IN. AND I THINK OUR
QUESTIONS HAVE BEEN ANSWERED
BUT A VICE CHAIR WOULD YOU CARE
TO MAKE A MOTION. A MOVIE.
THANK YOU N. I THANK YOU SO
MUCH MATTER BY SHARE AND YOU
KNOW I. WOULD SAY COMMISSIONER
WE WILL HAVE OUR TWO MEMBERS
BACK HI AND- I APPRECIATE YOUR
TIME AND I HOPEFULLY YOU HAD A
CHANCE TO TALK WITH THEM
TYPICALLY WE DO HAVE OUR
CHANCES TO MEET WITH-
APPOINTEES BEFORE THE HEARING
SO I WANNA SAY THANK YOU FOR
ANSWERING ALL OF OUR- QUESTIONS
AND GIVEN US YOUR THOUGHTS ON
AND WITH THAT WE HAVE A MOTION
FROM OUR VICE CHAIR. MADAM
SECRETARY WILL YOU CALL THE
ROLL. ROUV KAMLAGER LAYERED
BATES HI BATES AYE ATKINS HI A
CONCISE ON CALL THANK MISSIONER
THIS WILL BE ON CALL. YOU CAN
CHECK BACK IN IF YOU WANT I
SORT OF HAVE NO DOUBT GIVEN
THAT THE FORMER SECRETARY OF
NATURAL RESOURCES IS QUITE
FAMILIAR WITH YOUR WORK THAT WE
SHOULD. ANTICIPATE A POSITIVE
OUTCOME BUT YOU'RE YOU'RE
WELCOME TO HANG AND WATCH BUT
WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
OKAY FROM WE WILL TAKE A FIVE
MINUTE BREAK OUR RECESS AND WE
WILL BE BACK IN IN FIVE MINUTES
WITH GREAT THANKS TO
OUR COURT REPORTER- WE'RE GOING
TO CONTINUE NOW ON ITEMS ONE B.
AND C. UNDER GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEES REQUIRED TO APPEAR
THAT IS THE APPOINTMENT OF TWO
MEMBERS TO THE INDEPENDENT
SYSTEM OPERATOR GOVERNING BOARD
AND THAT WOULD BE THE
REAPPOINTMENT OF MISS MERRY EAT
LESLIE AND THE APPOINTMENT. OF
MYSTERY AND CHAUDHRY AND I WANT
TO SAY WELCOME TO BOTH OF YOU
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE-
WHAT WE WILL DO IN ORDER WE
WILL START WITH MISS LESLIE AND
THEN MOVED TO MISSOURI OUT
YOU'RE WELCOME TO MAKE OPENING
COMMENTS ACKNOWLEDGE ANYONE YOU
WOULD LIKE TO AND AFTER BOTH OF
YOU HAVE INTRODUCED YOURSELF.
WILL GO TO- RULES COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FOR QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS AND I WILL ASK OUR
RULES COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO
EITHER DIRECT YOUR QUESTION TO
ONE OR THE OTHER- OF THE
COMMISSIONERS AND THEN- FOR THE
GOVERNING BOARD- AND THEN- IF
YOU WANT TO ASK BOTH TO RESPOND
JUST MAKE THAT CLEAR SO THAT
AS- YOU KNOW WHAT TO EXPECT AND
WE KNOW WHAT ORDER THINGS CAN
GO IN FOR. OUR SAKES RELATED TO
THE REMOTE HEARING SO WITH THAT
MISS LESLEE WELCOME OUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD- ALL RIGHT GOOD
AFTERNOON MY HONOR TO BE HERE
TODAY AS GOVERNOR NUISANCE
NOMINEE FOR APPOINTMENT FOR THE
AYE SO BOARD OF COMMISSIONERS I
WANT TO THANK YOU CHAIR ATKINS
AND ALL OF YOUR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FOR THE TIME AND
COMMITMENT YOU'RE PUTTING INTO
THIS IMPORTANT RESPONSIBILITY
HAVING NOW SERVED ON THE AYE
AYE SO. BOARD FOR MORE THAN TWO
YEARS- GREAT RELIABILITY IS
STILL THE NUMBER ONE ISSUE THAT
THEY SUCCESS IN REACHING OR
EXCEEDING OUR CALIFORNIA
CLIMATE GOALS I'M PROUD THAT AS
A BOARD WE HAVE WORKED HARD
WITH STAFF FOCUSING ON SUMMER
READING LIST FOR THAT LOAD
SHEDDING ADVANCE IT'S OUR
HIGHEST PRIORITY WE ARE WORKING
WELL AND COLLABORATIVELY WITH
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION. AND OTHER
STATE AND REGIONAL STAKEHOLDERS.
AS A CALIFORNIA NATIVE IN MY
FAMILY HAS BEEN HERE FOR OVER
FIVE. GENERATIONS OUR ROOTS ARE
IN THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY MY
GRANDMOTHER GREW UP ON A RANCH
IN. IN FRESNO MY GRANDFATHER
WAS A MEMBER OF THE PIONEERING
FITS OUR FAMILY WHO HELPED. WHO
HELPED CREATE AGRICULTURE IN
AND THE DEVELOPMENT OF THAT IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY. MY FAMILY
HAS REALLY HELPED ME UNDERSTAND
THE RICH HISTORY A VARIETY THE
EXPERIENCES IN OUR GREAT STATE.
AND MY FIRST YEARS OUT OF
COLLEGE I SPENT IN SACRAMENTO
IN THE CAPITAL WITH ASSEMBLY
SPEAKER PRO TEM AND SOON TO BE
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR LIAM
MCCARTHY. ALTHOUGH MY CAREER
BEGAN AS SACRAMENTO IT TOOK ME
TO WASHINGTON DC NINE TO LA
WHERE I MET MY HUSBAND. ALAN
ARKIN TOP WHO IS JOINING HERE
TODAY ON SOON HE IS AN EDUCATOR
AND FACULTY MEMBER OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA. TOGETHER WE RAISED
OUR TWO SONS JACOB AND MICHAEL
WHO I HOPE WE'RE ALSO WATCHING
TODAY BUT IT IS A WORK DAY FOR
THEMSO I'M NOT SURE. AND
JOINING ME FROM THE BAY AREA'S
MY MOM JOAN LESLIE AND I WANT
TO THANK THEM ALL FOR THEIR
SUPPORT AND LOVE. AND AS YOU
KNOW I'M CURRENTLY PRESIDENT
CEO THE L. A. BUSINESS
COUNSELING INSTITUTE WHERE I
FOCUSED ON INTERNATIONAL AND
DOMESTIC OF ARNOLD AND ECONOMIC
ISSUES FOR MANY YEARS. AT THE
L. A. B. C. AND ALSO ON THE ICE
AWARD I JUST TRIED TO
DEMONSTRATE HOW ECONOMIC AND
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES ARE NOT
MUTUALLY EXCLUSIVE BIG DEEPY
INTEGRATED. THANK YOU TO OUR
ECONOMIC COMPETITIVENESS SOCIAL
JUSTICE HEALTH AND WILL BE. SO
IT'S MY PLEASURE TO BE WITH YOU
TODAY AND I LOOK FORWARD TO OUR
DISCUSSION ON THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE. THANK YOU MISS LESLIE
MISSOURI GO RIGHT AHEAD. YES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL AFTER
MARY'S INTERACTION I HAVE TO
ADMIT MY HUSBAND. WENT FISHING
SO I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE K. AT
ANY RATE I DO A PRE. THIS TODAY
TO BE HERE WITH YOU. TO TALK
ABOUT MY PENDING CONFIRMATION
TO THE ISO'S BOARD OF GOVERNORS.
AS YOU HEARD FROM THE- FROM THE
COMMISSIONERS- DISCUSSION. M.
FROM MERRY IS COMMENTS
DECARBONISING THE ENERGY SECTOR
IT'S NOT JUST A STATE GOAL IT'S
THE MANDATE SB ONE HUNDRED
REQUIRES US TO GET TO. A 100%
RENEWABLE PORTFOLIO STANDARD
MEETING ALL OF OUR ELECTRIC
ENERGY NEEDS. BY TWENTY FORTY
FIVE WITH RENEWABLE ENERGY IT'S
THE ISO'S JOB TO PRESERVE
RELIABLE ELECTRIC SERVICE WHILE
ALSO ENSURING THAT THE STATE
CAN MEET THOSE CLIMATE GOALS.
THE ISO IS PROVING THAT IT CAN
BE DONE EACH AND EVERY DAY WE
SEND A NEW RENEWABLE ENERGY USE
RECORD OF OVER 90% IN APRIL SO
WE ARE GETTING THERE WE'RE
DOING. LAST SUMMER'S AUGUST
TWENTY TWENTY HEAT STORM
REMINDED US ALL OF THE CRITICAL
ROLE ENERGY HAS IN OUR ECONOMY
AND OUR DAILY LIVES. AND HOW
IMPORTANT THE ISO'S RELIABILITY
RESPONSIBILITY IS TO THE
CITIZENS OF OUR STATE. I SPENT
ALMOST THIRTY YEARS AT SMUD
SACRAMENTO'S PUBLICLY OWNED
ELECTRIC UTILITY THE FIRST
FIFTEEN AS LAWYER AND THEN
GENERAL COUNSEL. AND ALMOST
FIFTEEN THEREAFTER AS THE CEO
AND GENERAL MANAGER. AND I THEN
SPENT. THE LAST TWELVE YEARS AS
THE NORTH AMERICAN ELECTRIC
RELIABILITY CORPORATION OR
NETWORK. BOARD MEMBER WORKING
ON BOTH GREAT RELIABILITY AND
CYBERSECURITY I THINK I WILL
BRING SOME REAL WORLD
OPERATIONAL EXPERIENCE TO THE
BOARD AS WELL AS EXTENSIVE
EXPERIENCE AS A BOARD MEMBER
AND I DO WANT TO CONTINUE
WORKING IN THE PUBLIC INTEREST.
THE CHALLENGE IN MY VIEW THAT
WE ARE FACING IS A BIG ONE I'D
LIKE TO BE PART OF FIGURING OUT
HOW WE CONTINUE TO MEET BOTH OF
OUR BOTH OUR RELIABILITY AND
OUR ENVIRONMENTAL OBJECTIVES.
THANK YOU AND I LOOK FOR YOUR
QUESTIONS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
BYE AND- I WISH YOUR HUSBAND
LOOK AND THE FISHING REGARD
UNLESS HE'S JUST MEDITATING OUT
THERE OF WHICH- I UNDERSTAND- I
THINK THE VICE CHAIRMAN I WILL
ASK SENATOR COM LONGER SHE
WANTS TO START US OFF SAID SHE
IS MULTI TASKING WITH TO
COMMITTEES TODAY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR I WILL-
TRY TO KEEP MY COMMENTS BRIEF I
APOLOGIZE FOR NOT BEING ABLE.
TO MEET WITH THE TWO OF YOU ALL
BUT I READ- YOUR APPLICATIONS
AND RESPONSES TO THE QUESTIONS
AND I AM. AM PRETTY CONFIDENT
AND HOW TODAY IS GOING TO GO-
AND IN GREAT AND GRATEFUL FOR-
YOUR SERVICE IN THIS SPACE AND-
A HEARTY HELLO TO MERRY LESLIE
WHO COMES FROM LA AND- WE'VE
WORKED IN THE PAST ON A NUMBER
OF ISSUES SO. I LOVE WHEN WE
HAVE REPRESENTATION FROM LA ON
THESE VARIOUS COMMISSIONS- I AM
GOING TO START WITH-
COMMISSIONER STORY- DID I
PRONOUNCE YOUR NAME CORRECTLY
AND- YES I WAS LIKE SEASHORE
CHAUDHRY PERFECTO- AND REALLY
SORT OF CURIOUS AND WANTED TO
KNOW IF YOU COULD SORT OF SHARE
YOUR THOUGHTS ON ON. THE BUDGET
ON- THE GRIT AND OUR GRID
SECURITY AND WHAT YOU THINK ARE
SOME OF THE GREATEST THREATS.
ARM TO OUR GREAT SECURITY IN
CALIFORNIA- AND ARE YOU
CONCERNED THAT ARE GREAT COULD
SUCCUMB TO. THREATS SIMILAR TO-
THE COLONIAL PIPELINE. YES AND
NO WHICH IS NOT A GREAT ANSWER
BUT LET ME EXPLAIN A LITTLE BIT
FIRST I WILL SAY. OF IT IS
DIFFERENT IN THAT THE ELECTRIC
GRID IS OPERATED UNDER
MANDATORY CYBERSECURITY
STANDARDS BOTH PHYSICAL
SECURITY CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE PROTECTION AS
WELL AS CYBER SECURITY IT
SOFTWARE TECHNOLOGY ETCETERA
THE GAS INDUSTRY RIGHT NOW DOES
NOT HAVE ANY STANDARDS THAT
THEY HAVE TO MEET AND THAT WAS
PART OF THE CHALLENGE WITH WHAT
HAPPENED WITH THAT PIPELINE
FAILURE AND THERE'S A BIG
ARGUMENT GOING ON RIGHT NOW
ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT MAYBE THE
GAS INDUSTRY NEEDS TO MOVE IN
THE DIRECTION THE ELECTRIC
SECTOR SO WE DO HAVE MORE
PROTECTION. FOR THE GRIP. THEN
THE GAS PIPELINE SYSTEM DOESN'T
IN THE COUNTRY THE WORRYING
THOUGHT THOUGH IS THAT WE DO
HAVE A LOT OF RELIANCE ACROSS
THE NATION. IN MEETING OUR
ELECTRIC GRID MEANS WITH GAS
PIPELINE SUPPLY SOURCES SO IT
IS A BIG ISSUE. THERE ARE TWO
KINDS OF. CHALLENGES I THINK ON
THE CYBER FRONT COMING OFF OF
THE NEW RECORD WASTE A LOT OF
TIME WORKING ON THIS WEEK'S WE
FOCUSED ON NATION STATE
CHALLENGES AND THIS IS REALLY
TRYING TO THINK ABOUT WHAT KIND
OF STUFF THE STUFF MAYBE BEING
CARRIED OUT BY RUSSIAN MY CHINA
MY NORTH KOREA BY IRAN ALL THE
COUNTRIES THAT MAYBE ACTUALLY
ATTEMPTING TO HACK THE GRID AND
TAKE IT DOWN FOR. ILLEGAL OR
MILITARY REASONS. AND THEN THE
SECOND ONE AND THIS IS WHAT
WE'RE REALLY STARTING TO SEE
HAVE A LOOTING. GOING ON THIS
YEAR IS RANSOMWARE. YOU HAVE
PRIVATE INDIVIDUALS WHO JUST
WANT THEIR CRIMINALS AND THEY
YOU THINK ABOUT THE STATE HAS
ALREADY TAKEN SOME GOOD STEPS
AS COMMISSIONER- THE NEW JUST
TALK ABOUT IN TERMS OF HAVING A
CENTRAL. FOCUS OFFICE TO TRY
AND WORK ON THESE ISSUES. BUT I
DO THINK IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT
EVERY COMPANY HAVE BOTH GOOD
TECHNICAL SOLUTIONS WHERE
THEY'RE ATTEMPTING TO. STOP THE
ASSAULTS THEY'RE COMING IN AS
WELL AS TRAINING OF STAFF
BECAUSE WE'RE DISCOVERING THAT
A LOT OF THESE CHALLENGES ARE
COMING IN. THROUGH EMAILS AND
PHISHING ATTACKS AND- EMPLOYEES
OPENING THINGS THAT THEY SHOULD
BE OPENING SO I CAN ASSURE YOU
THAT. MY LIMITED TIME SO FAR ON
THE ISO BOARD. IT'S CLEAR THAT
THE ISO ENGAGES IN THOSE
ACTIVITIES I KNOW THAT THAT
ALSO. IS THAT KIND OF TRAINING.
THAT KIND OF- THE SECURITY
SYSTEM SUPPORT IS BEING DONE BY
ALL THE UTILITIES IN CALIFORNIA
THAT ARE. MORE OR REGISTERED
ENTITIES THAT ARE UNDER THE
NETWORK MANDATORY CYBERSECURITY
STANDARDS. SO IT MIGHT CONTENT
TO SLEEP AT NIGHT KNOW EVERY
MORNING I GET UP AND IT SEEMS
TO ME WE'RE SEEING SOME NEW
CHALLENGE THAT'S COME OUT.
BECAUSE THIS IS AN EVOLVING
AREA I DO THINK THE ELECTRIC
SECTOR IS POSITION BETTER THAN
THE GAS SECTOR RIGHT NOW. THANK
YOU FOR THAT- INCREDIBLY
INFORMATIVE AND SOBERING- I
COMMISSIONER LESLIE I WANTED TO
ASK YOU A QUESTION SINCE THIS
IS A REAPPOINTMENT FOR YOU- IN
AB E. YOU CAN SORT OF SHARED
SOME OF WHAT YOU'VE
EXPERIENCED- DURING YOUR TIME-
AS A ARE ON THE BOARD. HOW DO
YOU THINK THAT THE BOARD CAN
SUPPORT BRINGING MORE STORAGE
TECHNOLOGY ON TO THE GRADE WE
HAVE BEEN ENGAGED IN SO MANY
DISCUSSIONS ABOUT THE DIFFERENT
KINDS OF- ENERGY THAT ARE OUT
HERE DIFFERENT KINDS OF
PRODUCTS AND THE NEED TO SORT
OF BUILD THAT UP SO YOUR
THOUGHTS ON HOW THE BOARD CAN
SUPPORT- THAT KIND OF EXPANDING
DIVERSITY. THANK YOU SENATOR
AND ON LIKE HE SAID I'M PROUD
TO BE FROM LOS ANGELES AND ONE
OF YOUR CONSTITUENTS I BELIEVE
HERE IN. IN US- LA MOM. I THINK
IT'S AN EXCITING TIME FOR
BATTERY STORAGE ON RIGHT NOW WE
HAVE ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED
MEGAWATTS ON THE GRID THAT
WE'VE WE FULLY INTEGRATED-
THANKS TO SOME REALLY GOOD
INTERAGENCY PLANNING THERE'S AN
ADDITIONAL TWO THOUSAND
MEGAWATTS THE CQC HAS
COMMISSION THAT'S HEADING FOR
US THE END OF THIS SUMMER I
THINK WHAT IT MEANS IS THAT
WILL HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
HAVE CLOSER TO TWO THOUSAND
MEGAWATTS. OF BATTERY STORAGE.
ON THE GRID AND FOR US AND WITH
OUR NET PEAK- POWER NEEDS FOR
RELIABILITY IN THIS IS NOT A
CRITICAL ISSUE THAT WHEN I CAME
ON TO THE BOARD YOU KNOW THE OF
THE. STOCK CURVE RATE IT SHOWS
THAT YOU KNOW WE GOES OFF ALL
OF A SUDDEN YOU NEED A LOT OF
ENERGY SO. BATTERIES FOR US OR
PLUS ABOUT STORAGE IS. IT
WHAT'S GOING ALLOW US TO FLY
AND THAT KERR. AND HAVE GREATER
ROLE. SENATOR SO I CAN YOU'RE
SEE A LOT MORE OF THAT AND I.
AT THE PRIOR COMMISSIONER BEEN.
EXPLAIN THIS IF YOU SEE-
REQUIRED AN ADDITIONAL ELEVEN
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED MEGAWATTS
OF ENERGY RESOURCE ADEQUACY
THAT THEY'RE LOOKING FOR BY
TWENTY TWENTY THREE TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE HELLO BE ADDITIONAL
BATTERY STORAGE THERE AS WELL
GREAT THANK YOU I KNOW THAT MY
COLLEAGUES ON THE BOARD ALSO
HAVE QUESTIONS SO- THESE WERE
THE ONLY TWO THAT I. REALLY HAD
I'M JUST EXCITED I THINK THIS
IS ON- AN AMAZING SPACE AND
THERE'S SO MUCH TO LEARN M. AND
I THINK THE PLAYGROUND IS JUST
YOU KNOW REALLY VIBRANT IN
TERMS OF WHAT WE CAN DO- AS A
STATE- WITH DIVERSIFYING OUR
ENERGY FIGURING OUT HOW TO. YOU
KNOW GET MORE OF IT AND RETAIN
IT MAKING GLUE GREENER CLEANER
CHEAPER AND MORE ACCESSIBLE-
AND I REALLY BELIEVE THAT YOU
ARE A VERY INTEGRAL PART OF
THAT PUZZLE SO. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SERVICE. THANK YOU SENATOR
MEADOW VICE CHAIR YEAH. WELL
THANK YOU TO BOTH OF YOU FOR
STOP BEING SO WILLING TO
SERVING HAN AND- YOU KNOW RENO
THAT'S GOING TO BE TIME MORE
AND MORE AND MORE IMPORTANT AS
WE LOOK AT CLIMATE CHANGE AND
HOW WE'RE ADDRESSING AN AGENT
HOPEFULLY A HOW WE'RE MANAGING
IT IN AND DOING MUCH BETTER
THAN WE THOUGHT WE WOULD DO. AS
WE SIT HERE IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE I THINK WE'LL START WITH
M'S LESLIE AS A RETURNING
MEMBER- AND ACTUALLY COMMEND
YOU FOR THE WONDERFUL
PRESENTATION YOU MADE YOU YOU
APPROACH IT WITH SUCH A
POSITIVE OUTLOOK. THAT'S GOOD
VERY GOOD FOR THOSE OF US AND
ME IN PARTICULAR NOT THAT
FAMILIAR WITH HOW IT ALL WORKS
I'VE NEVER SERVED ON THE ENERGY
OF COMMITTEES ARE- WHILE I'VE
BEEN A PUBLIC. ELECTED
OFFICIALS AT LOCAL LEVEL COUNTY
LEVEL AND NOW UP HERE SO I
LEARNED SO MUCH EACH TIME WE GO
THROUGH ONE OF THESE THESE-
NOMINATIONS AN APPOINTMENT
PROCEDURES FOR PEOPLE IN THAT
BUSINESS AND CERTAINLY YEAR AT
THE HEADWATERS SO START WITH
YOU BECAUSE IF I IF I DON'T
CLEARLY SOMETHING THAT'S OF
CONCERN TO ME AS- THE- MASSIVE
INFRASTRUCTURE COSTS WE MIGHT
BE LOOKING OUT. AS WE TRIED TO
IMPLEMENT THE GOVERNOR'S
ELECTRIC VEHICLE MANDATE I
THINK THE- ENERGY COMMISSION
NOT RECENTLY- REPORTED THAT
DEGRADE NEEDS THE EXPAND BE
EXPANDED THREE FOLD AND-
PERHAPS EVEN MORE THAN MATCHING
AND- WILL NEED TO OVER A
MILLION- A CHARGING STATIONS TO
ACCOMMODATE I THINK WE'RE
TALKING FROM MY RESEARCH HERE
PRESENTED TO ME ON ABOUT EIGHT
MILLION. ARE ELECTRIC VEHICLES
COULD BE ON THE ROAD AT THAT
TIME SO WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS
AS WE'RE APPROACHING THAT TIME
AND WHAT THOSE COSTS MIGHT BE A
HOW WE MANAGE THOSE I'M
CONCERNED THAT IF IT FALLS ON
RATE PAYERS WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
THE SAME SITUATION THAT WE HAVE
WITH OUR LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES
HAVING- YOU KNOW VERY DIFFICULT
TO MEET SOME OF THE COSTS THAT
THEY HAVE TO EXPERIENCE NOW SO.
JUST KIND OF AN OPEN. ENDED
QUESTION MISS LESLIE YOUR
FOUGHT FOR ON ALL OF THAT AND
ARE WE GETTING THERE ARE. YOUR
YOUR POLICY THINKER THINK SO
KNOW WE'RE TO GET THEIR TELL ME
HOW. YEAH THANK YOU FOR OF
KNOWLEDGE BEING THAT THAT- YOU
KNOW YOU HAVE TO BE POSITIVE I
THINK BECAUSE ON IT IT IS
CHALLENGING AND I WOULDN'T. YOU
KNOW IT'S NOT FOR THE FAINT OF
HEART I DON'T THINK I THE
ENERGY BUSINESS. YEAH YOU'RE
GETTING OUT THERE IN IN THE IN
THE TRENCHES YOU KNOW EITHER
WORKING ON PROGRAMS OR MANAGING
UTILITY LIKE G. AND YOU KNOW
YOU CAN'T JUST JUMP INTO THIS
BECAUSE EVEN WHEN YOU GET THERE
SENATOR IT'S STILL LIKE THEY'RE
SPEAKING ANOTHER LANGUAGE YOU
LIKE YOU'VE LANDED ON THE MOON
I CAN'T AS A NEW CONDITION
MIGHT HAVE EXPERIENCES A COUPLE
TIMES EVEN WITH ALL HER UTILITY
EXPERIENCE THAT THAT THAT
THERE'S A LOT TO LEARN AND
ACTUALLY WHAT THAT'S WHAT MAKES
IT REALLY A GREAT PLACE TO BE
BECAUSE YOU TAKE ALL YOUR
EXPERIENCE AND YOU COMBINE IT
WITH THE THINGS YOU NEED TO
KNOW. AND THEN HOPEFULLY WE CAN
GET A BETTER RESULT BECAUSE WE
ARE NOT THE TECHNICAL EXPERTS
SENATOR THE TACKLE IS FOR ITS
FOR THE OUTSTANDING STAFF OF
THE ICE SO YOU KNOW I'VE BEEN
IN GOVERNMENT ON AND OFF FOR
THIRTY YEARS AND I'VE SEEN A
LOT OF PLACES OPERATE BUT THE
ICE SO IS A IS A TOP NOTCH
OPERATION I MEAN THE
PROFESSIONALISM OF THIS GROUP
IS REALLY INSPIRING YEAH I
THINK THEY'RE PROBLEM SOLVERS
AND THEY HAVE TREMENDOUS
TECHNICAL SKILLS AND THAT'S WHY
I'M OPTIMISTIC I'M JUST I'M NOT
OPTIMISTIC FOR NO REASON YOU
KNOW I LIKE YOU FEEL LIKE YOU
HAVE TO BE CONVINCED SOMETIMES
YOU SHOW ME WHAT YOU'VE GOT YOU
KNOW I WOULD. ACTUALLY BE ABLE
TO DO THAT SO IN THE SPIRIT OF
THAT I DO NOT THINK THE
GOVERNOR HAS ENTERED INTO THIS
COMMITMENT LIGHTLY I THINK HE
HAS THOROUGHLY ANALYZED IT AND
TAKING A LOOK AT IT AND I THINK
HE DOES NOT WANT TO COST MORE
AND I THINK WHAT WHAT HE'S
THINKING IS THAT
ELECTRIFICATION IS KEY TO
GETTING TRIED 2% RENEWABLE
GOALS IN A COST EFFECTIVE WAY
AND THE REASON I SAY THAT IS
BECAUSE. IT DOES CREATE MORE.
THE MAN. THE THAT'S FOR SURE.
BUT THERE ARE MORE PAID PEOPLE
PAY INTO THE GRIT. AND
HOPEFULLY THOSE COSTS ARE
LOWER. THAN WHAT THEY WOULD BE
PAYING FOR OTHER FORMS OF.
ENERGY SO I THINK THAT OUR
FRIENDS AT THE CC. COMMISSIONER
OCCURRING THAT ARE REALLY THE
ONES WHO HAVE DONE THE FOR
CASTING TO TELL US WHAT WE NEED
THEY'RE TELLING US WE'RE GOING
TO NEED AS YOU SAID AT LEAST
ONE POINT TWO MILLION CHARGERS.
AT LEAST EIGHT MILLION EV'S
THEY'RE THEY'RE FIGURING WILL
BE ON THE ROAD AND THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WOULD BE
APPROXIMATELY I THINK ABOUT
EIGHT THOUSAND MEGAWATTS OF NEW
ENERGY. NOW AT THE ICE SO WHAT
WE DO IS WE STUDY. AND ANALYZE
THAT AND THERE ARE PROTOCOLS IN
THERE ARE PROCESSES THAT ARE
REQUIRED AND THAT'S- THAT'S THE
STAGE RING SENATOR IS THAT
WORK. OR ANALYZING RIGHT NOW
HOW THAT WILL WORK IN OUR
ABILITY TO. TO INTEGRATE IT BUT
I HAVE EVERY CONFIDENCE GIVEN
EVERYTHING ELSE I'VE SEEN AYE
SO INTEGRATE. THAT THEY WILL BE
ABLE TO DO THAT. AND THEY WILL
BE ABLE TO GET OUT OF COST
EFFECTIVE. WAY AND AS YOU KNOW.
BUT I SO HAVE AN ENERGY ABOUT
MARKET WITH ABOUT. ENTITIES
RIGHT NOW WILL HELP ALMOST
TWENTY THREE IN TWO YEARS 180%
OF THE WESTERN GREAT WITHIN.
THE NEXT TWO YEARS AND SO WE
ARE SPREADING. THE OPPORTUNITY
AND THE RISK ACROSS THE WESTERN
GREAT IN AND THE SAVINGS THAT
HAVE COME FROM THIS
INTERACTION. MEANS THAT WE HAVE
SAVE MONEY IN TERMS OF- OF
DELIVERING ELECTRICITY WILL
ALSO BE ABLE TO. MOVE POWER
THAT WEWOULD OTHERWISE HAVE TO
CURTAIL INTO. OTHER MARKETS AND
I THINK IT WILL BE A REALLY
IMPORTANT PART OF- OUR SUMMER
READING S. BECAUSE LAST SUMMER.
THE E. I AM PRODUCING
ADDITIONAL SIXTEEN HUNDRED
MEGAWATTS WHEN WE WERE
EXPERIENCING TIGHT SUPPLY SO
THAT WAS CRITICAL. SO WE HAVE
PARTNERS IN THIS WE HAVE WAYS
TO REDUCE OUR COSTS- AND I DO
FEEL CONFIDENT. WE'LL BE ABLE
TO DO IT EVERY SIX CALLS. SEVEN
THE CONSUMER AGREE US OUT THERE.
WELL WHENEVER AGAIN GIVEN
ANOTHER DIME ON THE UTILITY
BILL THEY'RE NOT REAL HAPPY SO.
ANYWAY I APPRECIATE THAT AND I
WOULD HOPE THAT BECAUSE YOU
SEEM TO HAVE VERY STRONG
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE THREE
ENTITIES THE I SO THE EASY AND
P. YOU SEE THAT YOU ARE WORKING
TOGETHER THAT THERE WILL BE A
REPORT I KNOW THE LAST ONE THAT
WAS PRODUCES TWENTY SEVENTEEN-
THAT'S PROBABLY ANTIQUATED NOW
BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN THROUGH A-
FEW MORE CHALLENGES SINCE THEY
ON. THAT THAT WE HAVE SOMETHING
VERY TANGIBLE THAT WE CAN START
TO SHARE WITH OUR CONSTITUENTS
WHO ARE THE CONSUMERS AND FOR
THE FIRST LINE OF DEFENSE WHEN
THINGS GO WRONG OUT THERE LIKE
WHAT HAPPENED AND WHY DIDN'T.
OF THINGS WORK THE WAY WE HOPE
THEY WERE OR THE WAY THEY WERE
PROMISED SO IF YOU COULD GIVE
US SOME EXTRA ENERGY TO THAT-
AND GETTING A REPORT OUT AND
SOMETHING TO THE LEGISLATORS.
EARLIER THAN LATER THAT WILL BE
EXTREMELY HELPFUL- TO ALL FOR
ALL OF US AS THE CONVERSATIONS
GO FORWARD I'D LIKE TO TURN NOW
TO MISSOURI AND DOG. I'LL JUST
GIVE YOU ANOTHER OPEN ENDED
QUESTION OF WE DID SUFFER THOSE
BLACKOUTS IN TWENTY TWENTY AND
THERE WAS A LOT OF THE BLAME
GAME GOING ON WHICH IS PART OF
OUR THEIR ARENA THAT WE ALL
LIVE IN. THAT DOT HOW ARE WE
LOOKING FROM YOUR PERSPECTIVE
AND YOU'VE BEEN SO INVOLVED IN
OUR LIVES THAT ARE FLOOD SO YOU
YOU WERE ON THE FRONT LINES
THAT CERTAINLY THROUGH A NUMBER
OF THE CHALLENGES THAT CAME
WITH THIS EXTREMOPHILE. IN YOUR
SERVICE SO HOW ARE WE LOOKING
FOR THE FORMER COMING UP AND
DOG HAVE WE PROCURED ENOUGH OR
WE ARE RECOVERY READY FOR MIGHT.
THAT MIGHT TO FALL OFF. WELL
JUST BEFORE YOU GET ON THIS THE
THIS MEETING. I AT THE ONE TIME
WEATHER REPORT AND SAW THAT
SACRAMENTO IS GOING TO BE A
HUNDRED AND EIGHT AND A HUNDRED
NINE THIS WEEKEND RIGHT.
FORTUNATELY IT'S ON THE WEEKEND
WHICH HELPS THE GRID- BUT ON
THE OTHER HAND THEY HAVE THOSE
KIND OF TEMPERATURES BECAUSE I
USED TO WHEN I STILL WORKED ITS
MIND AS YOU MENTIONED. UP TO
MONITORING VERY CLOSELY
BECAUSE- LOTUS VERY MUCH DRIVEN
BY AIR CONDITIONING. AND AIR
CONDITIONING IS DRIVEN BY
TEMPERATURE AND WE ALL KNOW
THAT AND THE CHALLENGE THAT WE
SAW LAST SUMMER IS THAT THE
TEMPERATURE OF THE HIGH TEMPS
DIDN'T HIT JUST IN CALIFORNIA.
THEY HIT EVERYWHERE AND WE'VE
ALREADY SEEN THAT. THIS YEAR
WITH REALLY ALARMINGLY HEIGHT
RECORD SETTING TEMPERATURES IN
BRITISH COLUMBIA. IN SEATTLE
AND PORTLAND WITH THE SERIOUS
CONSEQUENCES BECAUSE PEOPLE
DIDN'T HAVE COOLING CENTERS AND
THEY WERE PREPARED TO HANDLE IT.
I THINK THE CHALLENGE FOR US
GOING INTO THE SUMMER IS THAT
WE- PUT TOGETHER AS MANY
SOLUTIONS JOINTLY FIRST I WANT
TO COMMEND THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION THE ISO. AND THE
ENERGY COMMISSION FOR WORKING
HAND IN GLOVE AND THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE I'M- TRYING
TO DO EVERYTHING WE COULD DO.
IT FOR THE SUMMER WHAT WE
DIDN'T THANK OR WHAT I DIDN'T
THINK AT THE TIME IS THIS
SUMMER MEANS NOW NOT AUGUST
INSPECT HIM- LIKE IT WAS LAST
YEAR WE'RE ALREADY SEEING THE
HIGH TEMPERATURES. SO WE DO
HAVE MORE GENERATION WE HAVE.
ALL SERIES OF MARKET MAJORS
THAT WERE JUST APPROVED BY FURK
UNDER THE ISO TERRACE THAT
HOPEFULLY WILL HELP BRING MORE
ENERY AND WHEN WE NEED IT- WE
ALSO HAVE NEW PROVISIONS THAT
RELATE TO. RESOURCE ADEQUACY TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE PLANTS AND
PROJECTS AND DEMAND SIDE
RESOURCES THAT WERE COUNTING ON
DURING THESE CRITICAL PERIODS
WILL ACTUALLY BE THERE. SO
WE'RE TIGHTENINGUP ON HOW TO
COUNT THE MAN RESPONSE
RESOURCES WERE REQUIRING UNITS-
POWER PLANTS THAT NEED TO TAKES
SCHEDULED MAINTENANCE OUTAGES
MAKE SURE THAT THEIR STANDBY
ENERGY AVAILABLE TO COVER FOR
THEM BEING GONE. THERE'S A
WHOLE LIST OF MAJORS AND I FEEL
LIKE. A LOT OF THE VERY HARD
WORK HAS BEEN PUT INTO TRYING
TO THINK ABOUT WHAT CAN WE DO
TO EKE OUT EVERY LAST. HELLO
AND KILOWATT HOUR THAT WE CAN
TO BE READY FOR WHAT IS.
PROVING TO BE A VERY TOUGH
SUMMER WE'RE ALREADY SEEING
THOSE VERY HIGH TEMPERATURES
AND ON TOP OF THAT WE HAVE
DROUGHT IN AS A RESULT WE END
UP WITH LESS HYDROELECTRIC.
PRODUCTION SO YOU MAY HAVE SEEN
SOME SOMETHING IN THE NEWS THIS
LAST WEEK THAT AGAIN IN
PARTNERSHIP. WITH THE P. YOU
SEE IN THE ENERGY COMMISSION.
THE ISO IS NOW OUT ON THE
STREETS I THINK THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO BE GETTING THE
PROPOSAL STAND TODAY. FOR SOME
ADDITIONAL POWER TO COVER WHAT
WE ARE NOW ANTICIPATING IS EVEN
POTENTIALLY. A BIGGER ISSUE
THAN WHAT WE FORESAW A FEW
MONTHS AGO. SO IT'S VERY
CHALLENGING I DO THINK THAT
PEOPLE. REFOCUS COLLABORATING.
AND I THINK EVERYONE
UNDERSTANDS THE SERIOUSNESS OF
WHAT WE'RE DEALING WITH AND
PARTICULARLY AS YOU MENTIONED
WITH MICE MY BACKGROUND AND
HAVING LIVED THROUGH THE FIRST
ENERGY CRISIS. I KNOW WHAT IT'S
LIKE WHEN PEOPLE ARE STUCK IN
ELEVATORS ARE WHEN THEY'RE
REFRIGERATION FAILS AT THE
GROCERY STORE AND THEY CAN'T.
CONTINUE TO SELL THE FOOD
BECAUSE NOW THEY'RE VIOLATING
THE HEALTH STANDARDS BECAUSE IT
HASN'T BEEN REFRIGERATED OR ON
ICE LONG ENOUGH. HOSPITALS THAT
HAVE TO GO ON BACK UP
GENERATORS WORK THE SHERIFF
CALLING SOMEONE NEEDS. TO TALK
ABOUT THE FACT THAT THE TRAFFIC
LIGHTS AREN'T WORKING AND
HAVING A LOT OF THE- ALL THESE
WITH TRAFFIC. SO IT'S FROM THE
BUT IT DOESN'T TO THE SMALL BUT
IT'S NEVER SMALL TO THE PERSON
WHO'S EXPERIENCING AT. I CAN
JUST ASSURE YOU THAT I DO THINK
THAT PEOPLE ARE VERY FOCUSED ON
MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE DONE
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO BE READY
FOR IT. BUT WE ARE IN FOR A
TOUGH SUMMER YEAH SO THAT WOULD
BE MY ASSESSMENT WE ARE RIGHT
NOW. THANK YOU FOR THAT
MAJORITY BUT I THINK WHAT WAS
REALLY CAME THROUGH IN YOUR
DISCUSSION IS THAT BASED ON
WHAT HAPPENED LAST YEAR- WE'RE
NOT SITTING HERE ON INFORMED IN
AND NOT NOT. TAKING ACTION AND
SO THOSE ARE ALL GOOD THINGS
THE HEARING AND WE CAN'T BE-
RESPONSIBLE I GUESS OR
ACCOUNTABLE FOR EVERY SINGLE
THING THAT NOBODY ANTICIPATED
WHATEVER HAPPENED BUT I THINK
THE PUBLIC SKATING VERY OB. UP
LET'S SAY THEIR PARTNER IN VERY
WELL IN TERMS OF BEING CAREFUL
ABOUT THE WAY THEY DO USE OF
AIR CONDITIONING AND ALL THAT I
KNOW IN MY COMMUNITY FIVE.
CERTAINLY THAT COMES THROUGH SO
I THANK YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR
SERVICE BY JUMPING INTO THE
FREE EXTREMELY IMPORTANT TO.
ARENA IT IS FIVE FOR FULFILL
BASIC CALL CERTAINLY TO OUR
WELL BEING IN OUR COMMUNITIES
AND IN OUR IN OUR STATE FOR
SURE SAW YOU YOU BOTH ARE ARE
WELL QUALIFIED WELL INFORMED-
VERY IMPRESSIVE. SO YOU WILL
CERTAINLY HAVE MY SUPPORT WE
GET TO THAT THAT MOMENT. OF AND
WITH THAT. AGAIN THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SERVICE. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR ORRIN HATCH. SAID LANE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR. AND I
APOLOGIZE BECAUSE I WAS IN THE
BUDGET COMMITTEE FOR YOUR
OPENING STATEMENTS AND DIDN'T
GET A CHANCE TO HEAR THEM AND I
THINK SOME OF THE THINGS I
MIGHT ASK HAVE BEEN ASTOR
DISCUSSED BUT- STILL ALL BE
BRIEFER AND- THE ONE QUESTION I
WAS GONNA ASK GOVERNOR SHORE
YOU JUST SORT OF ADDRESSED BUT
LET ME SEEIF YOU HAVE ANYTHING
YOU WISH TO ADD TO IT BECAUSE-
DO YOU BRING A UNIQUE
BACKGROUND HAVING BEEN THE-
GENERAL MANAGER AND CHIEF
EXECUTIVE OFFICER FOR A LOCAL
UTILITY DISTRICT AND BRINGING
IT. TO THIS AND- HE I JUST
SUSPECT THEY'LL BE TIMES IN
DEBATES ARE DECISIONS. WHEN
YOU'LL BE ABLE TO SAY THIS IS
HOW THAT THIS WALL OF REFLECT
ON THE GROUND THIS IS INTERNAP
STRENGTHENING. HOW WOULD YOU
SPEAK TO ANYTHING ELSE YOU
WANNA SAY ABOUT YOUR ABILITY TO
DO THAT GIVEN YOUR EXPERIENCE.
YES THANK YOU THAT'S PROBABLY
ALREADY HAPPENED MEMORIES FROM
HIS SMILING A LITTLE BIT AS YOU
ASK THAT QUESTION- MY LEGAL
EXPERIENCE IT'S NOT THAT I WAS.
INVOLVED IN FERTIGATION AND AS
YOU ALL KNOW BURKE IS A EVERY
THE ISO IS A FOR. REGULATED
ENTITIES SO I THINK THAT WILL
BE HELPFUL. I SPENT MANY MANY
YEARS LICENSING AND BUILDING
POWER PLANTS OF ALL KINDS
RENEWABLE GAS AND- ALSO WORKING
ON CUSTOMER DEMAND PROGRAMS.
AND I ALSO DID A LOT OF POWER
CONTRACT NEGOTIATIONS SO I
THINK I HAVE A LOT OF JUST
PRACTICAL EXPERIENCE IN THOSE
AREAS AS ISSUES MAY CROP UP
THAT I MAY BE ABLE TO MAKE A
CONTRIBUTION. LATER AS THE CEO
WHICH I DID FOR ALMOST FIFTEEN
YEARS. FROM THE PICTURE I WAS
RESPONSIBLE FOR RESOURCE
PLANNING WHICH IS WORK AND
STRATEGIC PLANNING WHICH IS
WHERE YOU TAKE A LONGER VIEW
YOU'RE NOT JUST LOOKING FOR
SORT OF THE DAY TO DAY
MANAGEMENT ISSUES BUT ALSO
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT. WHAT ARE
YOUR GOALS AND HOW DO YOU GET
THERE AND PARTICULARLY WHEN THE
GOALS HAVE BEEN ESTABLISHED IN
MY CASE BY A PUBLICLY ELECTED
BOARD. MY JOB IS THE MANAGER
THERE WAS TO FIGURE OUT HOW YOU
ACTUALLY GET THERE SO I'M
HOPING I AM SORT OF PRACTICAL
EXPERIENCE ON HOW TO SET- BUT
CREATE WHAT I USED TO CALL THE
PUNCH LIST OF WHAT YOU NEED TO
GET DONE. THE TASKS THAT NEED
TO BE ACCOMPLISHED AND SENATE
METRIC SO YOU MEASURE WHETHER
OR NOT YOU'RE ACTUALLY
ACCOMPLISHING WHAT YOU DO. AND
LAST BUT NOT LEAST I DID MANAGE
SMILED DURING THE ENERGY CRISIS
SO I HAD THE PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE OF LIVING THROUGH
THAT WITH THE CUSTOMERS AND I
KNOW ABOUT HOW SERIOUS THE
CONSEQUENCES OF ROLLING OUTAGES
CAN BEAT TO CONSUMERS. WHO ARE
ECONOMY THAT PEOPLE DEPEND ON
ELECTRICITY EACH AND EVERY DAY
FOR EVERYTHING THEY DO AT THIS
POINT. AND HOPEFULLY. I WILL
HAVE SOME. OF THE ABILITY TO
REFLECT THAT AS WE ENGAGE IN
DECISION MAKING AT THE HIGHEST
SO. LAST BUT NOT LEAST- WE
SPENT FIFTEEN YEARS I THINK ARE
MORE LITIGATING MARKET POWER
ABUSES SO ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT I THINK IS A CRITICAL ROLE
THAT PROBABLY DOESN'T GET
TALKED ABOUT AS MUCH. AT THE I
SO BUT IS ABSOLUTELY ESSENTIAL
IS THE ISO IS YOUR TOOL. USED
THE LEGISLATURE. OR ENSURING
THAT MARKET POWER ABUSES ARE
NOT GOING ON AND WE HAVE AN
EXCELLENT STAFF AN INDEPENDENT
STAFF. THAT WORK ON THOSE
ISSUES DAY AND NIGHT AND SO I
FEEL VERY COMFORTABLE. IN
TELLING YOU THAT. THEY GOT
THERE THEY ARE THERE I ON THE
BALL. THANK YOU THAT WAS VERY
COMPREHENSIVE AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE ISHOULD SAY THAT. I
AM VERY MUCH ENJOYED- OF THE
CHANCE TO TALK WITH BOTH OF
YOU. UP EARLIER THIS WEEK. AND
FOR GOVERNOR LESLIE LET ME JUST
ASK YOU- ONE OF THE THINGS YOU
SAID- IN OUR CONVERSATION AND I
DON'T KNOW HOW MUCH. THE
DISCUSSION HAS GONE TO CLIMATE
US FOR. IT SAID EXTREME WEATHER
COULD BE OUR NEW NORMAL. AND
GIVEN THE NEW NORMAL THAT HAS
EXTREME WEATHER WITH DRAMATIC
INFLUENCES ON THE GRID. HOW DO
YOU SEE YOUR ROLE AND SORT OF
TRYING TO PREPARE FOR THAT
DEALING WITH THAT. YEAH I WISH.
I WAS BEING FLAT BED I ACTUALLY
MANAGE I THINK THAT WE ARE
WE'RE AT THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
TWO YEARS AGO WHEN I FIRST WAS
SITTING THERE LIKE JANICE TODAY
WAS WE DIDN'T WE HAVEN'T
EXPERIENCING EXTREME WEATHER-
IT BAD IN THE ENTIRE WESTERN
GRID AT THE SAME TIME YEAH
THAT'S SUPPOSED TO BE ONCE
EVERY THIRTY YEARS RIGHT- BUT
THE TRUTH IS NOW WE HAVE TO
LOOK AT THIS EVEN WHAT WE'VE
SEEN SO FAR THIS YEAR AND AS
YOU KNOW IT'S EARLY JULY. THAT
THIS IS NOW. THE IMPACT OF THE
CHANGES IN OUR CLIMATE ARE
BECOMING MORE EVIDENT IN
EXTREME HEAT IN THE NORTHWEST
IS NOW. A REGULAR EVENT SO I
THINK IN TERMS OF OUR PLANNING
I CAN'T STRESS ENOUGH SENATOR.
THE DIFFERENCE WITH THE INTER
AGENCY PLAN. YOU KNOW EVERY
EVERYBODY WAS SORT OF IN THE
SILOS WHEN I FIRST SHOWED UP
NOBODY IS IN A SILO ANYMORE
EVERYBODY TALKS TO EVERYBODY.
IN FACT YOU KNOW OUR OUR NEW
CEO. ELLIE IT MEANS- NEEDS
PLANS REGULAR MEETINGS WITH NOT
ONLY HIS COLLEAGUES TO SEE IF
YOU SEE AN SEC BUT ALSO THE
STAKEHOLDERS IN THE WESTERN
GRID AND OF COURSE ALL OUR
STAKEHOLDERS AS PART OF OUR
YEAH YEAH. SO WE NOW HAVE A
VERY LARGE AUDIENCE INCLUDING
YOURSELF IN THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE THAT WE
ARE COMMUNICATING WITH
REGULARLY AND THE BENEFIT OF
ALL THAT IS THE ENHANCE
COMMUNICATION COOPERATION. NOW
HAS TIGHTENED UP THE PLANET. SO
THAT THAT SENATORS WERE
CONCERNED. YOU KNOW INITIALLY
AFTER THAT THE LOAD SHEDDING
LAST SUMMER THAT WE DIDN'T HAVE
A PLAN GOING INTO THIS SUMMER I
ASSURE YOU THAT IS NOT TRUE WE
ABSOLUTELY HAVE A PLAN GOING
INTO THE SUMMER RIGHT. I DON'T
KNOW HOW MUCH MORE WE COULD DO
IN TERMS OF OUR PREPARATION AND
AS JAN WAS SAYING WE WOULD
TAKEN SEVERAL ACTIONS RECENTLY
IN WHICH THE CAPACITY
PROCUREMENT MECHANISM. WAS
ISSUED EARLY THIS MONTH FOR A
THIRTY DAY NOTICE OF UP TO
THREE THOUSAND MEGAWATTS OF NEW
CAPACITY WHICH AS YOU KNOW OUR
DELTA LAST SUMMER WAS ABOUT
FOUR THOUSAND MEGAWATTS SO. I
THINK WE HAVE WHERE AT A VERY
GOOD PLAN OF HOW WE WILL BE
PREPARED NOW WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN IS WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO
STAY PREPARED. I DON'T THINK.
YOU KNOW THIS BETWEEN ME THE
EXTREME HEAT B. WHAT USED TO BE
THE SUMMER FIRES RIGHT THERE
ARE THAT ARE ARE ARE ARE
TURNING INTO POTENTIALLY MORE
YEAR ROUND FIRES I THINK.
YOU'RE SEEING THAT- ALL OF THE
DIFFERENT AGENCIES DOING
EVERYTHING THEY CAN DO AS WELL
AS ALL THE LOS SERVING
ENTITIES. YOU KNOW HARDENING
THEIR GRADES. YOU KNOW IT I
THINK WE KNOW WE'RE PREPARING
WE'RE GETTING READY AND THE
GOOD NEWS IS OUT OF THE
TRANSITION- AND REINVEST WE DO
THIS KNOWING WE HAVE TO BE
RESILIENT. AND THAT'S A BIG
DIFFERENCE NO YOU HAVE TO BE
RESILIENT IS THAT IS THAT IS
PERSON IS JUST DOING IT LIKE
YOU USED TO IT'S A VERY
DIFFERENT WAY OF LOOKING AT
THINGS AND I THINK WE'RE VERY
MUCH. OF THE MIND THAT WE HOW
WE THAT WE HAVE TO BE A RESERVE.
EVERY IS. SYSTEM THANK YOU ARE
REALLY. THE ANSWER. YOU MIGHT
HAVE THOUGHT YOU'RE BEING
FLIPPED WHICH YOU'RE BEING
ACCURATE. SO FIVE FIVE I REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT- AND I'M GOING
TO BE VERY COMFORTABLE WITH
COFFEE THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
APPRECIATE THE CHANCE TO ASK
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU SENATOR
AND OBVIOUSLY GIVEN YOUR
BACKGROUND AND MORE RECENT
HISTORY IT'S GREAT TO HAVE YOU
A PART OF THESE DISCUSSIONS AS
WE- CERTAINLY TAKE UP. THESE
TYPES OF APPOINTMENTS WHETHER
WE'RE TALKING ENERGY COMMISSION
THE CPUC AKAU I SO I JUST DUG
COMMENTED TO A STAFF MEMBER I'D
LOVE TO BE A FLY ON THE WALL AT
ONE OF YOUR COCKTAIL PARTIES OF
INCREDIBLY BRIGHT PEOPLE. HI I
AMNOT KIDDING ACTUALLY IT
WOULD BE QUITE AN ENJOY
ENJOYABLE THING TO HEAR- THE
BACK AND FORTH- I THINK MY
COLLEAGUES HAVE ASKED A LOT OF
THE QUESTIONS I HAVE ONE
QUESTION FOR BOTH OF YOU- AND
ALL I'LL LET YOU GO FIRST MISS
LESLEE- SINCE YOU'VE GOT
SENIORITY ALTHOUGH LISTENING TO
BOTH OF YOU I GOTTA SAY. AGAIN
ALL REFERENCE THE COCKTAIL
PARTY- HOW CONFIDENT ARE YOU
THAT ENTER IN INTO A REGIONAL
GRID WON'T JEOPARDIZE
CALIFORNIA'S CLEAN ENERGY
POLICIES AND- REALLY WHAT I
MEAN BY THAT AS- YOU CONTINUE.
TO- HI OF LOOK AT TRACKING.
WILL THE IMPROVE TRACKING OF
SECONDARY DISPATCH INSURE THAT
ARE THE PARTICIPATING ENTITIES
ARE BACKFILLING RENEWABLE
ENERGY RESOURCES WITH FOSSIL
BASED PRODUCTION. AND THE
REASON I ASK THAT IS I THINK
THAT'S PART OF WHY WE'VE HAD
THIS YEAR'S A LONG.
CONVERSATION AND SORT OF
DISAGREEMENT OVER GOVERNANCE.
AND THE ROLE OF THE LEGISLATURE
AROUND I HAVEN'T SOME- INPUT
WITH CAL AYSO THROUGH THIS
APPOINTMENT PROCESS IF AND I
THINK BOTH OF YOUR FOR PROBABLY
FAMILIAR WITH THAT LONG.
CONVERSATION IN HISTORY SO MISS
LESLIE DO YOU WANT TO START
JUST COMMENT ON ON THAT FROM
THE BROAD VIEW- APPRECIATE.
REAL THAT THE SENIOR MEMBER. NO
I REMEMBER SENATOR AL WELL THE
FIRST THING I ALWAYS LIKE TO
SAY WHEN ASKED THIS QUESTION IS
YOU KNOW THE ULTIMATE DECISION
RESTS WITH. YOU SENATOR AND THE
LEGISLATURE RIGHT THERE IS NO
CHANGE IN GOVERNOR'S THERE'S NO
REGIONALIZATION WITHOUT THE
STATE LEGISLATURE SO YOU WOULD
HAVE TO BE. YOU WOULD HAVE TO
BE. YOU KNOW YOU WOULD HAVE TO
FEEL REALLY CONFIDENT THAT IT
WASN'T CALIFORNIA'S INTEREST
TO. TO DO THAT. THEN THEN I
WOULD SAY THAT A HORSE ARE ONLY
LAWS PROTECT US RIGHT YOU CAN'T
INSURE SOMETHING THAT
CALIFORNIA'S A LOT SO EASY- YOU
KNOW. WHAT WE'RE CRITICIZED
BECAUSE AS WE PROCURE WE'RE
TAKING CLEAN ENERGY OUT OF THE
OTHER WESTERN STATES RIGHT
THERE THERE IS THE REVERSE
ARGUMENT ACTUALLY NOW WHAT I
LIKE ABOUT THIS ENTIRE
DISCUSSION IS HOW THE FIELD
CHANGE RIGHT NOW YOU KNOW WHEN
WE AGAIN TO TWO AND A HALF
YEARS AGO YOU DIDN'T HAVE THIS
ALIGNMENT OF WESTERN STATES
WITH YOU KNOW EVEN ARIZONA IN
AND OF BAD AT IT YEAH WE HAD
OREGON WE HAVE WASHINGTON WE
DON'T CALL AROUND. THESE STATES
ARE ALL ADOPTING THEIR OWN
CLEAN ENERGY GOALS FOR THEIR
STATE SO ADDS THAT ALIGNMENT AS
AN ALIGNMENT THE CURSE OF
AGREEING THAT THIS IS OUR
FUTURE THAT YOU KNOW THAT THAT
THAT MAKES. IT MUCH MORE
APPEALING FOR IT DOESN'T. FOR
US TO HAVE A MORE TO CONSIDER A
MORE INTEGRATED GREAT NOW THE
WAY I LOOK AT IT IS YOU KNOW
THE E. I AM. WE STARTED THE I
AM THE E. IDEA NOW HAS SIXTEEN
PARTNERS RIGHT- THOSE ARE THE
ENERGY IMBALANCE MARKET
PARTNERS. AND WITHIN FEW YEARS
OR LESS WILL HAVE TWENTY THREE
PARTNERS WILL HAVE 80% OF THE
WESTERN GRIT. NOW WHAT IT WHAT
WHAT HAS HAPPENED SINCE WE
CREATED THIS PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE SIXTEEN WELL WHEN WE WERE
IN TROUBLE LAST SUMMER. WE HAD
AN ADDITIONAL SIXTEEN HUNDRED
MEGAWATTS WE WOULDN'T HAVE HAD
IF WE HADN'T HAD THE
RELATIONSHIP RIGHT WE WOULD'VE
IN TEXAS KIND OF BY OURSELVES
YEAH HEY. WE WERE HAPPY WE HAVE
A PARTNERSHIP TO GET THE
SIXTEEN HUNDRED EXTRA MAY
WHAT'S WE'RE ALSO VERY HAPPY
THAT IT SAVED US. OVER A
BILLION DOLLARS YOU KNOW IN
COST. AND THAT WE HAD WHEN WE
WHEN WE CREATED IN A QUOTE
OVERSUPPLIED ENERGY CLEAN
ENERGY WE HAD A MARKET TO SELL
INTO RIGHT WE DON'T HAVE TO
CURTAIL ANYMORE. SO ALL THE
EVIDENCE IN MY OPINION ABOUT
THIS WESTERN RELATIONSHIP WITH
THE IBM IS FAVORABLE. NOW WHEN
YOU GO TO THE NEXT STEP THE EDM
RIGHT BECAUSE THOUGH THE I AM
STRAINING 5% YOU KNOW IT'S A
REAL TIME MARKET RETREATING 5%
REAL TIME MARKET. THE NEXT
THING WE'RE DOING IS WE'RE
WE'RE TAKING A LOOK AT MODELING
THE EDEA THEY HAD MARKET
BECAUSE THEN YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT TRADING HOW 2% THE ENERGY
WAS SOMETHING. THAT WERE
MODELING THAT WE'RE SEEING THAT
WE'RE SEEING THE BENEFITS. WITH
WITH THE PLUSES AND NEGATIVES
OF THAT ARE. AND AS YOU KNOW
SENATOR. DIFFERENT DIFFERENT.
STATE HOW ISSUES WITH. THEY
AGREE WITH THOSE A PERCENT SO
BUT I THINK THE DECISION ABOUT
TRADING IS A DIFFERENT KIND OF
DECISION NOW BUT IT ONLY WORKS
IF YOU CAN PROTECT YOUR OWN YOU
KNOW YOUR OWN STANDARDS YOUR
OWN LOSS YOUR OWN REQUIREMENTS
FOR PROCUREMENT SO I THINK IT'S
ONE OF THOSE I THINK WE'RE
STILL WAITING AND SEEING BUT
RIGHT NOW THE EVIDENCE IS
LEANING TOWARDS. THE WESTERN E.
I AM HAS REALLY BEEN A GOOD
THING FOR CALIFORNIA. SURE
ANYTHING YOU WANNA ADD TO THAT
YEAH I WAS GOING TO SAY LET ME
THAT WAS A GREAT ANSWER RIGHT
MARY BUT I'LL GO AHEAD. WITH A
LITTLE MAYBE A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT WRINKLE FIRST OFF
I'LL SAY IT DOESN'T MATTER
WHERE YOU ARE EVERYBODY WOULD
LIKE TO FIND THE CHEAPEST STUFF
THEY CAN. NUMBER ONE.
CALIFORNIA EVERY DAY IS
DEMONSTRATING THAT. RENEWABLES
WORK. THAT THEY ACTUALLY CAN
MAKE LOAD. THAT THEY ARE
AVAILABLE THAT YOU CANNOT SIGN
CAPACITY VALUE TO THEM THAT
THEY DO OPERATE THE WAY THEY'RE
EXPECTED TO OPERATE. AND DURING
THE PERIODS WHERE THE SUN IS
NOT SHINING OR THE WIND IS NOT
BLOWING I'M NOT BLOWING YOU CAN
BACK THEM UP. WITH BATTERIES
AND WE'RE STARTING TO
DEMONSTRATE WE'VE SHOWN A
NORMA'S PROGRESS IN MY VIEW.
AND WHAT WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO DO
WITH BATTERIES AND OTHER
STORAGE TECHNOLOGIES AND THIS
CONCEPT OF A HYBRID SOLAR
PLANT. THAT BASICALLY USES
SOLAR ENERGY SURPLUS SOLAR
ENERGY TO RECHARGE ITS
BATTERIES. IS REMARKABLE. AND
IS COST EFFECTIVE. AND IS GOING
TO BE VERY INTERESTING TO
PEOPLE ACROSS THE WEST. I THINK
THAT AS A PRACTICAL MATTER IF
YOU LOOK AT COAL PLANTS AROUND
THE WEST THEY ARE CLOSING
BECAUSE THEY ARE ON ECONOMIC.
IT DOESN'T ACTUALLY HAVE MUCH
TO DO WITH. MAYBE A STATE
POLICY IN WYOMING ABOUT. NOT
RENEWABLES IT HAS TO DO WITH
THE FACT THAT IT IS NO LONGER
ECONOMIC FOR THOSE PLANTS TO
OPERATE AND WE'RE CERTAINLY.
BASICALLY AFTER WHAT'S HAPPENED
THIS YEAR WE'RE STARTING TO SEE
A LOT OF VOLATILITY. IN GAS
PRICES AS WELL. SO FROM. FROM
THE VERY BIG PICTURE WE HAVE
MADE SUCH PROGRESS WITH THE
TECHNOLOGY AND THE COST. BUT I
THINK THAT WHEN PEOPLE ARE VERY
FOCUSED ON. WHAT'S THE MOST
EFFICIENT WAY TO DO THINGS
WHAT'S THE MOST AFFORDABLE WAY
TO GET ELECTRICITY TO
CONSUMERS. THEY'RE GOING TO SEE
THAT CALIFORNIA'S PATH IS
GIVING US THE ERROR. AND
THEY'RE GOING TO BE INTERESTED
IN FIGURING OUT. HOW DO YOU
INCREASE THAT. AND IF YOU ADD
GEOGRAPHIC DIVERSITY OF
RESOURCES SO THAT YOU SPREAD.
SO TO SPEAK YOUR FOOT PRINT OF
RESOURCES THAT YOU CAN MIX AND
MATCH. YOU'RE GOING TO COME UP
WITH BETTER COST STRUCTURE FOR
EVERYBODY. SO IT SEEMS TO ME
THAT. THE UNDERLYING ECONOMICS.
AND SO BORENSTEIN OUR BOARD IS
PROBABLY ONE BETTER THAN THAN
ME THE OTHER ONE ACT. ARE
DRIVING US TO THE CLEAN ENERGY
FUTURE THAT CALIFORNIA'S
LEADING ON. BUT THE ROLE THE
AYE AS WELL AS FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE IS HE PROVING IT
WORKS EVERY DAY. THAT'S OUR JOB.
WELL THANK YOU. THAT WAS THAT
WAS A- COMPREHENSIVE
SUBSTANTIVE I APPRECIATE THAT
FROM BOTH OF YOU THANK YOU- ALL
OF THE COLLEAGUES HERE HAVE I
THINK HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO ASK
QUESTIONS SO I THINK UNLESS
ANYONE ELSE HAS A COMMENT OR
QUESTION WILL GO AHEAD MOVE TO
MEMBERS OF THE PBLIC. THAT
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY AND SO
I'M GOING TO START OF COURSE
RIGHT HERE IN ROOM THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE. I AND OPEN IT UP TO
PEOPLE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. AND I AM
NOT SEEN ANYONE IN THIRTY ONE
NINETY ONE COME FORWARD I'M A
LOOK AT ROOM ONE TWELVE R.
SPILLOVER ROOM. AND I DON'T SEE
ANYONE SO I'M GOING TO WELCOME
BACK OUR TELECONFERENCE
MODERATOR. AND REMIND WITNESSES
WISHING TO CALL IN OF THAT TOLL
FREE NUMBER. 877-226-8189
ACCESS CODE. TWO EIGHT SEVEN
SIX ZERO FIVE NINE. N. AS WE
TEAR UP THE WITNESSES I WANNA
REMIND FOLKS- YOUR NAME
ORGANIZATION YOU REPRESENT IF
ANY AND YOUR POSITION OF
SUPPORT SPEAK CLEARLY AND
SLOWLY SO THAT WE CAN CAPTURE
YOUR COMMENTS OF WITH THAT
MADAME MODERATOR WELCOME BACK.
THANK YOU LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO BECAUSE THE
COURT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THAT TIME. AND
CURRENTLY WE HAVE FOUR IN Q.
WE'LL START WITH ONE EIGHTEEN
YOUR LINE IS NOW OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS TYLER CROWDEN ON BEHALF
OF AMERICAN CLEAN POWER
CALIFORNIA IN ENVIRONMENTAL
DEFENSE FUND. IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF GOVERNOR. LESLIE MANN SHORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH
NEXT WITNESS. MY TWENTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NUMBER TEN
MEMBERS ANYMORE SEVENTEEN THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY EFFICIENCY
AND DEMAND MANAGEMENT COUNCIL
IN SUPPORT OF BOTH
COMMISSIONERS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS. ONE TWENTY
FIVE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. PATRICK
WELCH WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT A BIT OF BOTH MISLED
LEE AND THE SHORT BIRD DRIVE
OUT THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. ONE TWELVE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. BERMAN CHAIR MEMBERS
INJURY AND TWENTY ON BEHALF OF
ADVANCED ENERGY ECONOMY- IT
SUPPORT- LESLIE AND MATURE. TO
BE REAPPOINTED TO THE ACTUAL.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. LINE
SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI THIS IS- JANSPORT BE
JONES WITH THE INDEPENDENT
ENERGY PRODUCERS AND- WE
WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT THE-
RECONFIRMATION OF MISSOURI
GOVERNOR LESLIE I WAS AN EXPERT
JOB AS- ON THE CURRENT BOARD OF
DIRECTORS AND- HE HAS- I DID A
GOOD JOB IN THE TRANSITION-
IT'S YOU KNOW THEY'RE GONNA
SENIOR MANAGEMENT- AND WE ALSO
OBVIOUSLY SUPPORTS- MISSOURI
THE MUSIC- THAT EXCEPTIONAL
BACKGROUND- IN THE ENERGY
SECTOR. AND I THINK MOST
IMPORTANTLY DEMONSTRATED THE
LAST TWELVE YEARS- FOCUSED ON
RELIABILITY WHICH- WE NEED TO
FOCUS ON AS- A MOVING FORWARD-
IN THIS ENERGY TRANSITION- AS
WELL AS A PRETTY EXTENSIVE
EXPERIENCE IN CYBER SECURITY-
WHICH HAS ALWAYS BEEN AN ISSUE
THAT THE IRS SO THEY'VE DONE A
GOOD JOB. AND I THINK I HAVE
BEEN HER EXPERTISE ON THE BOARD
WILL WILL ADD TO THAT DEPTH OF
KNOWLEDGE SO YOU HAVE TWO VERY
HIGHLY QUALIFIED PEOPLE- FOR A
SERVICE ON THE BOARD AND I. A
LOT OF THE ANCHORAGE YOU YOUR
EYES THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NEXT WITNESS. MY FIFTEEN
YEAR LINE OPEN. WELCOME ANA
RIVER THE NATURAL DEFENSE
COUNCIL MADAM CHAIR SENATORS
YOU'VE JUST GOT IN THIS HEARING
A VIVID ILLUSTRATION OF HOW
MUCH BETTER CALIFORNIA IS
EQUIPPED TO HANDLE CLIMATE
CHANGE ON ITS GRID THAN TEXAS
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT BOTH
MERRY LESLIE'S NOMINATION AND
JIM CHAUDHRY'S VERY LESLIE WHO
IS WELL KNOWN TO MY LOS ANGELES
OFFICE HAS EARNED THE RESPECT
AND APPRECIATION OF ALL WHO
WORK WITH THE AGENCY. TO ENSURE
YOU AS YOU NOW KNOW IS AN
ICONIC FIGURE IN THE
ELECTRICITY SECTOR CALIFORNIA
AND THE ENTIRE NATION WE URGE
AND I BOTH THANK YOU. THANK YOU
IMPRESSIVE TESTIMONY NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. BEFORE WE OPEN
MY TWENTY FOUR AND A REMINDER
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK UP OR YOU MAY
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME MY
TWENTY FOUR YEAR LINE UP.
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
CONFIRMATION OF BOTH VERY
LESLIE AND TO ENSURE IS MEMBERS
OF THE CALIFORNIA ISO GOVERNING
BOARD. THEY BOTH BRING UNIQUE
KNOWLEDGE AND EXPERIENCE TO
THIS IMPORTANT POSITION. AND WE
STRONGLY URGE YOUR RIVAL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
AND THERE IS NO ONE ELSE IN
JUDICIAL SUPPORT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM MODERATOR WILL
BE BACK IN A MOMENT. OKAY
HAVEN'T HEARD FROM WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT WE WILL MOVE TO THOSE
WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
I KNOW THERE IS STILL NO ONE-
IN ROOM THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE
APPROACH IN THE DIET SO I WILL
LOOK AT ROOM ONE TWELVE. ALSO
NO ONE SO MADAM MODERATOR BACK
WITH YOU FOR MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO APPETITE. AND ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO. AND WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT I'M HOPING. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR HELP TODAY MADAM
MODERATOR. OKAY SO HAVEN'T
HEARD FROM WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
AND GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
FOLKS TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
WE'LL BRING IT BACK AND I WILL
SEE IF THERE IS AN ICONIC
MOTION FROM A MEMBER OF THIS
BODY. BY LET ME INTO THE TO THE
GOVERNOR'S LET ME JUST SAY IT
DOES NOT ALWAYS GO THIS
SMOOTHLY SO- THAT'S A
COMPLIMENT OBVIOUSLY. TO YOU-
CENTER LAYERED YOU'RE LEANING
FORWARD YES AND I WAS GOING TO
MAKE A BRIEF COMMENT AND IF YES
OUR PROPOSAL OF WHAT YOU SAID
EARLIER ABOUT THE COCKTAIL
PARTY. AND DOES CERTAIN THINGS
HE I WAS AT THE BEGINNING OF
BEING RESOURCES SECRETARY AND I
WAS IN A MEETING WITH ONE OF
THE HIGH LEVEL. OFFICIALS OF
COWBOYS OF THAT SORT OF. A VERY
PER WE WANT TO KNOW WHY THE
ADMINISTRATION AND MADE SOME
DECISION AND WHY MIKE. MY
PARTICULAR AGENCY WAS DOING
SOMETHING AND I SORT OF HAD TO
SAY I'M RIGHT HERE. IN R. R. A.
N. WHAT IS REPRESENTED IN. IN
THE CURRENT ADMINISTRATION AND
THE PEOPLE THAT WE HAVE
INTERVIEWED IS A WHOLE SCALE
CHANGE. IN CULTURE. WHERE IT'S
NOT JUST ORIENTED TOWARD
CLIMATE IT'S NOT JUST HAVING
SOMEBODY IT'S A FORMER GENERAL
MANAGER THAT KNOWS HOW THESE
DECISIONS GO ON THE GROUND.
IT'S ALSO COLLABORATION IN THE
SENSE THAT I WAS JUST SURPRISED
WHEN CALISTO REACHED OUT TO ME
IN ONE TO WALK ME THROUGH. WHAT
MIGHT HAPPEN WITH POWER SHUT
OFFS AND THE POWER GRID OVER
THE SUMMER IS RELATED TO MY
DISTRICT IN THE STATE. AND THIS
IS REALLY DIFFERENT AND I THINK
IT IS REALLY REPRESENTED AT THE
TWO PEOPLE. THAT ARE IN FRONT
OF US TODAY SO I AM PLEASED TO
MOVE THEIR CONFIRMATION. THANK
SENATOR AND WE'RE GOOD WITH
BOTH AND ONE MOTION GREAT.
MADAM SECRETARY WE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. GROVE KAMLAGER HI I'M
LONGER HIGH LAYERED HI THERE I
BATES AYE BATES AYE ATKINS AYE
AYE THIN SEVENTY FORTY ZERO
FOUR TO ZERO- CONGRATULATIONS
WE WILL MOVE YOUR CONFIRMATION
TO THE SENATE FLOOR AND THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR TIME TODAY.
YEAH THANK YOU VERY MUCH. VERY
WELL MADAM SECRETARY WE NEED TO
OPEN THE ROLE FOR ITEM I FORGOT
ITEM ONE EIGHT. THE THING THE
CALL ON ITEM ONE EIGHTY. GROWTH
KAMLAGER I. THANK YOU AND- THAT
IS FOUR ZERO COMMISSIONER-
GUDAS- APPOINTMENT WILL MOVE TO
THE SENATE FLOOR WE CAN
HOPEFULLY GIVE HIM THE GOOD
NEWS. I AM WITH THAT THIS
CONCLUDES TODAY'S PUBLIC
PORTION OF THE AGENDA I WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU TO ALL THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT PARTICIPATED
IN OUR PUBLIC TESTIMONY TODAY.
IF YOU WERE NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY
PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
RULES COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR
WEBSITE FOR INSTRUCTIONS. I
ASSURE YOU YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE TRULY IMPORTANT
TO US AND WE WANT TO INCLUDE
YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORD SO WITH THAT
THANK EVERYONE FOR YOUR
PATIENCE COOPERATION TODAY ARE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON RULES WILL
NOW MOVE TO EXECUTIVE SESSION.